CLASS TO ORDER THANK YOU ALL
YOUR DAUGHTER SO LITTLE BIT OF
IT'LL START- THIS WASN'T OUT
WEST. YOUR STATE. IS. FOR
MAKING IT SO GOOD AFTERNOON AND
WELCOME ABOUT TAKE A MOMENT BY.
STOP THANK YOU MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID CHIU WHO
IS THE CHAIR OF THE STATE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING THE
ASSEMBLY OF A RANGE OF USE OF
THE STATE BUILDING IN OTHER.
WORDS FOR THIS MORNING THANK
YOU SHOOT. SINCE I. GOT WIENER
THE NUMBER FILL TING AND ALL
THE WAY FROM LA ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LAURA FRIEDMAN THE BIG. YES.
WE'RE GONNA SPEND UNDERSTAFFED
AND LOOK AT SOME SUCH AS
STRATEGIES FOR ALL. IT IS
CREATING NEW HOUSING IS A
PORTABLE CALIFORNIA'S MIDDLE
CLASS. GOING TO REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS ASSESSED SAYS I
AND WHAT IT JUST TEXT WE CREATE
GOALS. WELL IN HOUSING. WELL
LOOKING AT DEVELOPING IMPACT
FEES AND HOW LITTLE INCOME HOW
IMPACT BY THE WAY THE LOCAL
CHURCHES. DO YOU. MINOR STAYS
IN IS BEING WILL GIVE YOU SOME
WAS WEBSITE AS WELL ON FACEBOOK
NOW MY CAR IS ON THE SELECT
COMMITTEE WHO WERE NOT ABLE TO
JOIN US IT WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VIEW THE
HEARING. IN ITS ENTIRETY AT
THEIR. ALSO THE PUBLIC THE
SAME- OUR PANELISTS WILL SEVEN
TO TEN MINUTES EACH. IT WILL BE
FOLLOWED BY A QUESTION AND
ANSWER PORTION WELL. HAVE BEEN.
I'M FOLLOWING OUR PANELS OF
UNITY FOR A PUBLIC. BEFORE I
ALSO WANT TO KNOW YOU SEE IN
THE AUDIENCE IS SOMETHING TIM
GROUP. FROM THE- BANK BUT I
WILL JUST TO START OFF WITH A
BEFORE. IS PROVIDE OPPORTUNITY
EACH OF A CALL TO MAKE ANY
OPENING COMMENTS THEY MAKE. MR
SHOOT THAT STARTS OFF. TO THE
BAY AREA IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
WHEN THIS HEARING- YOU KNOW
MANY OF US WORK ON MANY AREAS
TO HOUSING POLICY PROTECT
TENANTS HOW WE ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS HOW WE BUILD MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT THIS THE
TOPIC THAT I THINK IS NEAR AND
DEAR TO ALL OF US. I WANT TO
THANK. FOR HIS LEADERSHIP OF
THE. FOCUS ON THE PLIGHT OF THE
MISSING MIDDLE THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS AMONG OTHERS THE BILL
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE FACT THAT
WE- ALL OVER THE STATE. OUR
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO
LIVE NEXT TO THE HIGH COST JOB
CENTERS THAT. AND WE FIGURE OUT
OUR TEACHER R. CHILDCARE WORKER
HEALTH WORKERS ARE RETAIL
WORKERS FOR TRANSPONDERS WE ARE
LIVE. IN OUR MIDDLE CLASS
BECAUSE- OF FAILURES AND
HOUSING POLICIES APPRECIATE ALL
OF OUR HOUSING WE'RE HERE YES
SIR MY STRONG HOPE IS THAT THIS
YEAR. OUR VARIOUS HOUSING
COMMITTEES. ANOTHER PROPOSALS
ADDRESSING HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY FOR OUR MIDDLE
AND WORKING. GLORIA THANK YOU
SIR. DID YOU I KNOW YOUR TIME
IS. COM THANK YOU SO MUCH I
JUST WANTED TO GET WELCOME YOU
HERE. WHICH IS GOOD THANK YOU
FOR PUTTING YOUR VERY POOR
SELECT COMMITTEE MEETING HERE I
THINK IT'S A- VERY IMPORTANT
TOPIC BE FEW AND SOME POINT
THERE WE WERE GROUND. ZERO FOR
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY ISSUES
REALLY SEEN ANY OF THOSE-
UNAFFORDABLE- SPIKES REALLY.
HAPPENS. TO WHICH IS REALLY HOW
DO WE PROVIDE HOUSING TO THE
MIDDLE CLASS. I WAS HONORED TO
BE WORK WITH A NUMBER OF OUR
COLLEAGUES. ON EXCESS GOING
UNITS WITH ASSEMBLY BLOOM WELL
AS I CAO SKI. AND WILL BE ABLE
TO. ALL SOLUTION TO THE MIDDLE
CLASS HOUSING BUT WE KNOW WE
HAVE A LONG LONG WAY TO GO- I
APOLOGIZE I CAN'T STAY FOR
PRESS THE PANELS. I HAVE STAFF
HERE WOULD REALLY INTEREST HERE
OTHER SOLUTIONS ARE COMING AND
REALLY JUST THANK YOU.
YESTERDAY THANK YOU SIR ANY.
MAKING INVOLVING HAVE DINNER
WITH. THANK YOU MISTER. AND A
CITY OR A CITY WHERE HOUSING
POLICY- MATTERS EVERYWHERE BUT
WERE AND SUCH IN EACH STATE I
HEAR IT SO IT SORT OF
EVERYTHING A LOT OF WAYS AND SO
THANK YOU FOR. IN HERE. HE YOU
KNOW I'M GLAD FOR THE FOCUS ON
OUR MIDDLE CLASS OR WORKING
CLASS BECAUSE WE DO. IN OUR LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS ARE AT THE
GREATEST RISK OF HOMELESSNESS.
CRISIS IS MOSTLY FOR LOW INCOME
PEOPLE AND WE WORK TO. FIVE TWO
FIVE INCREASES TO THE SUIT CAN
STABILIZE LONG AND BUT YOU KNOW
ALWAYS. A LARGE MAJORITY OF LOW
INCOME PEOPLE PRETTY MUCH ALL
MIDDLE INCOME PEOPLE LIVE IN
SO. I'M HOUSING AND REALLY FOR
THE MIDDLE CLASS- ALTHOUGH
SUBSIDY. YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN
WAYS ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM
ULTIMATELY FOR THE MIDDLE CLASS
WE NEED TO BUILD AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF NEW HOUSING WE NEED
TO DO IT STIR. AND WE DO IT
CHEAPER NOT CHEAPER IN TERMS OF
THE QUALITY OF THE HOME TO KEEP
FOR IN TERMS OF THE COST. WE
HAVE MADE IT WHERE THEY WAY
WOULD BE TO HAVE. HIS OWN IT.
PROP US THROUGH I AM IS IT. WAY
TOO HARD LONG EXPENSIVE TO GET
HOUSING BILLS AND WE'VE SEEN
THAT WITH THE COLLAPSE AND
HOUSING PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST FIFTY
YEARS THIS OF THAT WITH A MULTI
MILLION HOME DEFICIT. FORTY
NINE OUT OF FIFTY STATES IN
HOME. UPPER. CAP AND SO WE HAVE
TURNED THAT AROUND A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES. WE NEED
MODERN THE PRODUCTION OF ALL.
WHEN YOU DO IT YESTERDAY SO
LOOK FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSION
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATE. LEADERSHIP SUMMIT. ALL
THIS A QUICKLY I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR HAVING A DRINK. OUR
HOUSING CRISIS IT'S THE BIGGEST
PRICES THAT WE FACE IN LOS
ANGELES SO I REMOTE. FROM
CONCERT. AND I'LL JUST ADD WITH
YOU'RE JUST SAID ABOUT PEOPLE
WANTING TO KNOW WHERE THE
HOUSING IS FOR THEM AND THE
PENCIL THERE'S HOUSING IF YOU
ARE VERY POOR. THE LAST THING
ALTHOUGH THAT IS IN VERY SHORT
SUPPLY BUT IT DOES EXIST.
WEALTHY I'M YOU CAN USUALLY
FIND SOMETHING BUT IT'S THE
PEOPLE ARE JUST MIDDLE CLASS
THAT ARE BE. PLEASE BUT NOT
JUST A PURCHASE. THANK EVEN
FINDING A PLACE OF SOMEWHERE
CLOSE TO A NEW. I LIVE IN OR
NEAR THEIR JOBS AND I WOULD
JUST I GUESS OPEN WITH THE
QUESTION WHICH IS WHAT I HEAR A
LOT FROM CONSTITUENTS THAT THE
PROBLEM IS A MARKET
MANIPULATION AND GREED THAT
DEVELOPERS. BUILD FOR TAKE RENT
FOR THE PRICE. I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT'S COMPLETELY THE CASE OF
COURSE. TO MAXIMIZE THEIR
INVESTMENTS AT HAND. BUT I'D
LOVE TO HEAR FROM THE PANELISTS
AS THE GOOD PRESENTATION
WHETHER THIS. DEVELOPER CHOICE
TO WHAT OTHER FORCES AT WORK
THAT ARE MAKING IT DIFFICULT
FOR PEOPLE TO BUILD. UP. THAT
CAN BE RENTED FOR WITH A MIDDLE
CLASS A WORKING PERSON CAN
AFFORD. WHAT. I'M NOT EVEN
TALKING ABOUT BUILDING IN A
VERY HIRING AREA REALLY. SAN
FRANCISCO OUT. FOR GLENDALE OR
OTHER TO LOS ANGELES SO I.
THROW THAT OUT IS LISTENING FOR
AND I THINK THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE WATCHING AT HOME I'M
KIND OF THE SAME QUESTION.
THANKS AGAIN THANK YOU SO
MEMBER FREEMAN AT SOME OF A
GRAYSON IF YOU WANT TO JOIN IN
THE DESERT AND- SO GRATEFUL. TO
BE I KNOW YOU AND. SAY EARLY
THIS WEEK ON A REAL TOPICS WITH
YOU SIR. INTO OUR THAT'S ALL.
MELISSA FOR A PANEL TO COME ON
BOARD- FIRST TO SPEAK TO THE
COMMITTEE THIS AFTER HIS MOTHER
QUITE I WAS A HAPPY POP
SPECIALIST FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT- MELINDA
BEFORE. GEORGE AGAIN DORMAN.
THIS IS SUSIE. GOVERNMENTS OUR
FAVORITE ADVOCATE FROM THE. HE
WAS ON LAW AND POVERTY- AND THE
ROCK STAR HIMSELF STRAIGHT OUT
OF TEXAS A BILLABLE DIRECTOR
FROM THE CAN INSTITUTE OF URBAN
SEARCH AT RICE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIANS FOREVER TO. LIVE
GEOGRAPHICALLY. SO MONEY WE
TURN THIS OFF ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
TO YOU TODAY- MY NAME IS
MELINDA CLAY AND I AM A SEAT
POLICY SPECIALIST WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. I AM
PART MEANT WORKING WITH HOUSING
ON SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
AND HOUSING AND- TODAY I'M GOOD
INTRODUCING THE REGIONAL HOW.
TO PROCESS HOUSING ELEMENT LAW
FOCUSING. IS TO REQUIRE FROM
OUR IN HOUSE WHICH IS A
SLIGHTLY OVAL LEFT AND WHAT WE
MIDDLE INCOME HOW I'M IN THE-
RANGE. WILL HELP PROVIDE A TEXT
FOR YOU TO. SO THE- LAW WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE AND IS THE STATE'S PRIMARY
MARKET BASED ALLERGY TO
INCREASE HOUSING SUPPLY
PORTABILITY. WHEN HOUSING
ELEMENT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MUST
ONE PLAN FOR THE HOUSING NEEDS
IDENTIFIED FOR INCOME
CATEGORIES WHICH IS CALLED THE
REGIONAL HOUSING OKAY ARENA TO
REDUCE REGULATE. KNOWN AS
STRAIGHT AND THREE. PROVIDE
PLEASE. IN THE BALLOT OF HELP.
HOUSING THANKS TO THE GREAT TO
SEE. THE OBJECTIVES OF THE RINA
ARE TO INCREASE HOUSING SUPPLY
IN THE MIX OF HOUSING TYPES
PROMOTE INFILL DEVELOPMENT AND
SOCIAL NAMIK EQUITY NOT AN
IMPROVED REGIONAL BOB AND HOUSE
RELATIONSHIP FOUND HOUSE
HOUSEHOLD INCOME DISTRIBUTION
ANNA FOR REALLY FOR FAIR
HOUSING. SEVEN A QUICKLY GO FOR
THE RAIN ACROSS. AND IN A
STARTS FOR THE STATE LEVEL
WHERE IT NEEDS TO EMIGRATE UNIT.
CANCER CELLS LONGER. I'VE GOT.
NUMBER. REGIONAL LOT NEED PLAN
FOR A HOUSE ON IT OVER IT YOUR
PLAN. BUDGET TO ENSURE THAT IF
THERE IS THE OBJECT. THAT I
SPENT. THEN I DID MY TERRACE
THE BILL FAILED TO COMMENT THAT
ME AND HOW HELLO. IT IS D.
REVIEW HOUSE MEN'S AND THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT REPORT ON THE
PROGRESS IN KEEPING OBJECTIVES.
THE TRIP. ONE WAY IN THE
REDUCTION THE GOAL OF PLANNING
FOR THE NEEDS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS IS BY BREAKING THE
LOCAL ARE THE ORIGINAL NUMBER
INTO FOUR DIFFERENT CATEGORIES
WE CAN SEE HERE ON YOUR SCREEN.
DISTRICT THREE NOT. MR ACTION
THE FOUR OR IS VERY LOW HOUSE
LOW 50% OF AREA IN INCOME LOW
INCOME FIFTY EIGHT PERCENT.
THANK. WHICH IT 8010020% BOB.
HOUSE MAKING BOB. MEDIA.
SHOWING WHAT IS FOR ME- CAN SEE
HERE ON THE RIGHT AND- WHAT
ABOUT HOLD HOLD FOR ME TO
NINETY EIGHT THOUSAND AND AS AN
HUNDRED BEFORE. AN. SO THE
HOUSE INCLUDES THREE COMPONENTS.
THERE'S AN AVAILABLE AND
PERCENT WHICH INCLUDE SITE
VACATION SALT. THE RESULT
ACTION THAT ACTIONS IT EMBLEM
WITH HOUSING PLANNING. THESE
ACTIONS WE CALL WE ARE OFTEN
REFERRED TO AS PROGRAMS. IS IT
THE HELP OTHER CORPORATE ENOUGH
ARE THE I. VÀ K. SITE COMING
IN A BY. MIDDLE BUT- THE
IDENTIFY ASIAN AND REMOVAL
DEVELOPMENT THAT'S TAKEN THE
LAST BUBBLE AND ACTIONS THIS IS
THE RESULT OF THINGS. I'M OF
YOUR SCREEN WHAT ABOUT.
CURRENTLY THE HOUSING LAW
EXPLICITLY. HOUSE IN OUR IN THE
RESEARCH IN THE MIDDLE WILL
THEN PROGRAM THAT LAST.
JURISDICTIONS MUST INCLUDE IN
THE HOUSING ELEMENT PERSONAL
SPECIFIC THING PLAN AVAILABLE.
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT AND NOW
SYSTEM. STILL OTHERS ARE. TO
ACCOMMODATE. THERE HOW TO GO AS
I SHOT CHART. NOW MUST SHOW THE
SITE TO DOUBLE HOUSING ELEMENT
IS THE GOAL. FOR PEOPLE. HE
REALISTICALLY IT ON THAT PARCEL
SITES ACCOMMODATE THE LOWER
INCOME. HIGH AND LOW FOR
DEVELOPMENT OF A HOUSING.
LATEST DURING THE APPROPRIATE.
ARE LEFT BUT ALL IS NOT. AND BE
A MODERATE INCOME RATE IN A
CATEGORY. IT IS LOOK AT THE-
EXCHANGE THIS ON THAT. THAT IS
THE MOST APPROACH WAS IN.
OUTSIDE. OR THEIR OF MY INCOME
HOUSING FOR EXAMPLE IN THE SAME
BERMAN STICK AND- THIS WOULD BE
SITE ZONE FOR LESS THAN. TEN
BALLING IT'S PER ACRE. FOR MY.
IN A TYPICAL SEE THE IS A CITED
EITHER HIGHER DENSITIES FAMILY.
OR INTENSE USE. OR MODERATE
DENSITY MULTI FAMILY LET'S SAY
GET IN THAT SAME SUBURBAN
JURORS BETWEEN TEN AND- YES.
BUT WITH THE RIGHT CHANGE
SELECT PATIENT AROUND ACCESS.
DRAWING MY AGE HAS SEEN AN
INCREASE IN THAT ARE PURE
FICTION THAT ARE RELYING ON
TENSION OR- THE MODERN. IT'S
PRETTY EXCITING. I'M. SIX ON A
HOUSING PROGRAMS ALL HOUSING
I'M AS MUCH A CLUE TO SET IS AN
ACTIONS PROGRAM. ADDRESS AT
LEAST. DOCTOR THIS YEAR AND
PLACE WHERE THERE ARE SECTION
GOING TO ALSO HAVE TO INCLUDE
THE PROGRAMS TO PROMOTE. WELL.
WHERE THE RIGHT ANSWER. EACH
PROGRAM I THINK THIS ACTION
DEFINITIVE TIME LINES. TO IT
BEING AT EIGHT WHEN OF THE
HOUSING ELEMENT. TYPICALLY WHEN
REQUIRE IS THAT OUR STATE THIS.
MEANT OTHER INCOME HOW. ISN'T
IT IN. STREAM IN ABOUT CATION.
DOES FOR ACCESS SMALL WHEN IN
THE STORE. WHICH WE DO MORE
AFFORDABLE BY DESIGN. I WANTED
TO LEAVE YOU SOME UP SINCE MY
EXPERIENCE WORKING. WITH
HOUSING ELEMENT AND READ A LOT
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AS YOU
THINK ABOUT APPROPRIATE
POLICIES DRESS THE NEED FOR ME
WHEN COMPOSING. A LOT OF MONEY
EIGHT Y. WHICH WERE CENTER
FRIDAY OF THE HOUSING GETS WHAT
WHAT MIGHT. HOUSING THANK MAY
NOT RIGHT CONTACT ANOTHER GEN.
IN THIS NOT TO BEGIN WITH. MY
INCOME HOUSEHOLD. TO THE EXTENT
THAT WILL INCOME CATEGORY YOU
KNOW YOU ON A CONSIDER THIS
ZONING LOOK DIFFERENT FOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR MY THE COMMITTEE
WILL TAKE QUESTIONS AT THE END
OF FOR THE PATIENTS SO THAT
BRINGS US- TO GEORGIA WOULD
YOU- FORESHORES. I THANK YOU
I'M GEORGE AGAIN DOORMEN I'M
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF AREA
GOVERNMENTS ON A BAG IS THE
COUNCIL GOVERNMENTS FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA'S HUNDRED
ONE CITIES AND NINE COUNTIES
AS- MANY OF YOU KNOW. MELINDA
JUST TALKED ABOUT THANKS ROLE
AS THE COT IS STRIPPED. TO EACH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND THE BAY
AREA THERE. NUMBER OF HOUSING
UNITS BY INCOME ARE WE HAD AS
DETERMINED BY ATD. SO I WON'T
GO INTO THE DETAILS THERE
BECAUSE MONDAY ALREADY DEAD
BUT- I'M NOT FINDING IT NOTE A
BAG HAS. KICK OUR PUBLIC
OUTREACH FOR AT THE BAY AREA
NEED. TWENTY TWO TO TWENTY
THIRTY HOUSING PLANNING SIDE
WELL. I'M. I'M PLANNING KICK
THAT EARLIER THIS FALL. THE
DEADLINE FOR ELECTING OUR
RENOWNED CATIONS IS GONNA BE ON.
AND ONE SO. AND WE'RE- GONNA BE
PRETTY FAR ALONG TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND WE ARE THE BEST I'M
REGION IN THE STATE SO WE ARE.
THEIR BEHALF I KNOW I SPENT THE
REST OF THE STATE. AND AFTER
THAT YOU KNOW THE CITY IS THAT
AND TOWNS THAT WE WITH ARE
GONNA BE REQUIRED TO ZONE
APPROPRIATELY. I JUST WE WANTED
TO TAKE A MINUTE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE I'M A HUGE THANKS
THE LEGISLATURE FOR ALL THE
RECENT- RESOURCES THAT YOU'VE
PROVIDED I IN THE LAST SESSION
AND WITH SB TO. TO SUPPORT A
BAG IN OUR WORK AND DOING THIS
IMPORTANT PLANNING AND THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS FOR
EMPLOYMENT GEN. I'M. SO ONE
THING WE WANT TO TALK. ABOUT IS
THAT WE REALLY KNOW THAT AND
THEN BREAK DOWN. THAT'S IN THE
PAST I'M THE HOUSING SHORTAGE.
REALLY CUTE FIELD AND THE BAY
AND IT'S- OF LIFE. AND HAS THE
FIRST COALITION IN THE BAY AREA
TO COALESCE AROUND A THREE D.
FREIGHT TEN CENTS OF. WHAT WE
DO IS AN TAX CHALLENGE. SO THAT
THREE P. FRAME IS. IS
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE HOUSING AT
ALL INCOME LEVELS PRESERVE
PORTABLE HOUSING THAT ALREADY
EXISTS AND PROTECT CURRENT
TENANTS FROM DISPLACEMENT- WE
WERE REALLY HAPPY TO SEE ALL
THE WORK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DAN AND LAST. TO EMBRACE THIS
P. MARKET AND. THERE HAS ALSO
BEEN A LOT OF WORK IN THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS THE PLANNING
PORTION OF PRODUCTION. SEVENTY
IN WE SEEN I THINK IT DOESN'T
WORK AND HOUSING ELEMENT BELLS
BY MY COUNT. ON THAT ARE PUT
LOCALS AND RECONSIDER PLANNING.
A HOUSING THAT NEEDED TO COME.
WORK. WE NOW CYCLE IS GONNA
LOOK RELEASE CANTLEY DIFFERENT
EFFECT IN THE PAST AND THE
BIGGEST THING THAT WE IT ACTS
AND AGAIN WORK ON IN OUR CYCLES
WE DON'T FOR SURE WE EXPECTED
THE HD WILL SHOOT TO THE BAY
AREA ON A LARK OUR INCOME
TARGET THAN AND THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT- MODERATE TARGET
READ RECENT YEARS I'M MRS IN
THE CONTEXT ASIAN THAT THE
AREAS TOTAL HAPPEN NEED A
SIGNIFICANTLY COMPARED TO THE
SAME PERIOD. I'M ACTUALLY AT
THE KNOWLEDGE YOU. EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHT SENATOR WE SPELL I'M AND.
THANKS A- LOT IT IS ME NEWS AT
SKAGGS NUMBER- WAS THREEFOLD I
HAVE HAD BÀN YES CYCLE SO
LIMÓN IT'S KIND OF THIS ALL
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT. THE
OTHER PIECE THAT WOULD BE
DIFFERENT THAT'S BEEN FOR
MODERATE INCOME IS AT THAT
WORKFORCE HOUSING HAS REALLY
BEEN ELEVATED IN THE FAIR OUR
DISTRICT AND CONSIDERATIONS. SO
I'M WHAT. WHERE THE WHERE THE
WINDOWS AT DEVELOPMENT SHOULD
BE BETTER ALIGNED WITH PROJECT.
GROWTH TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
ADEQUATE LOOK HOUSING. AND SEND.
SENATE. MINIMIZING THE NEED FOR
PEOPLE TO FAR AWAY FROM WHERE
THEY WORK. AGAIN AT ALSO OVER
THE PAST THREE. NUMBER OF
HOUSING ELEMENT LAW UPDATES I
INTENDED TO PROVIDE THE POST
FREENET SITE TO ACTUALLY MADE
AVAILABLE TO. DATE THERE'S
HOUSING NEED SO. THE HOUSING
ACTION PROCESS IN THE PAST.
BECAUSE OF THAT WE THINK THAT
THE LEAD TEACHER BAGS POSITIONS
OF LEADERSHIP LET THIS PLAY OUT.
AGAIN THE DEEPENING OF A NEW
CYCLE YOU HAVE SOME TIME ASIDE
WHETHER FROM THE SIXERS ARE
WORKING ON AND GO BACK TO THE
DRAWING BOARD THE NEXT CYCLE
THEY GET. IF WE'RE NOT SEEING
WHAT WE WANT TO. ADEN AT. MAKE
THE CHANGES ARENA IS NOT MEAN
THAT WE DON'T THINK THAT
SACRAMENTO CAN DO TO HELP WITH
AFFORDABILITY FOR MIDDLE INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. CENTER WINNER
TALK ABOUT IT ALREADY OTHERS
HAVE ABOUT IT ALREADY THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF OUR INDECENT
SECOND TAKE INTO LOOK AT
REMOVING AND BARRIERS TO
PRODUCTION AT LOOKING AND
SOUNDING AND YOU KNOW MAKE
HOUSING THE GROUND. THE PROCESS
FASTER AND CHEAPER. AND ALSO
I'M HEADING INTO A MEETING. THE
DEEP SUBSIDIES THAT ARE NEEDED
FOR AFFORDABLE FOR HOUSING AND
THEN- ALSO THERE IS INVESTMENT
IN. IT'S NECESSARY. STORE UP
AND SEND TRANSPORTATION
IMPROVEMENT. TO MAKE WHEN
HOUSING CONS MAKE THE QUALITY
OF LIGHT I WORK. THE
ENVIRONMENT THE SECOND HEARING
OF THE- TODAY WHICH I REALLY.
AS YOU WELL KNOW MIGHT NOT ALL
INCOME MANY OF THEM ARE WORKING
CLASS BUT THERE AT THAT THE
VERY LOW IN BETWEEN THE LOW END
OF THE INCOME SCALE. IT SAY
THAT YOU THE CONTENT LET ME
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW
WE- SAYS HER MIDDLE INCOME. AS
WELL TRYING TO ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE AS WELL. I REALLY WANNA
AND. MELINDA AND ARE REALLY
BIRD M. RENO PROCESS SORT OF
ALL THE VARIOUS LAWS HAVE
CHANGED I THINK WE'LL HAVE HOPE
ARE GONNA PUT US ON A BETTER
PATH. ON THE LAND USE AND
ZONING AND IN THE FUTURE- BUT
BUT I JUST WANT TO DRILL DOWN A
LITTLE BIT- ON SOME OF THAT
JUST SO WE SORT OF UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S- GOING ON. BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S JUST REALLY
IMPORTANT. AND THE NATURE OF
THE CRISIS. SO IT YOU KNOW.
FOLKS ARE PROBABLY THEIR
STATEWIDE 76% OF EXPAND.
HOUSEHOLDS SO THAT. THEY'RE
MAKING THIRTY. IN CONTRAST.
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS THOSE WHO ARE
AT EIGHTY TO ONE TWENTY AM I
BEING. 4% SO 4% OF THEIR INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS STATEWIDE. I THAN
HALF THEIR INCOME IN RENT. NOW
SHIFT TO LOOKING AT YOUR SAID
LATE WE CALL THAT OVER FIFTY
FOR THE EXTREME COST. COST
BURDEN WHICH IS THOSE THAT ARE
OVER 30% LESS THAN 50% THOSE
NUMBERS AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE GO
CA. UP FOR THE MODERN
COMPOSED. THE BIGGEST BURDEN
CLEARLY AND THAT IS WHAT THE
MUCH LESS. ABOVE MINE IN THE
PROCESS 1% AND THEN ALSO SOME
IMMEDIATE HOUSEHOLD IS A HIGHER
PERCENT A MINE AND THEY'RE
GIVEN REGION CAN AFFORD RENT
THE AVERAGE RENT IN FIFTY TO
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA. AND IN 90% OF THE
STATE'S A COAT AS 10% OF THE
CODE WHERE THEY CAN'T OR SPREAD
ACROSS TWENTY SIX DIFFERENT
COUNTY SO THEIR POCKETS AND A
LOT OF THEM ARE NOT
SURPRISINGLY IN THE BAY AREA.
AND POCKETS OF LOS ANGELES AND
ALONG THE COAST. IT IT AND JUST
TO PUT SOME ADDITIONAL NUMBERS
TO THAT SO LOOKING AT A FEW
SPECIFIC CAPS AS EXAMPLES TO
HELP FURTHER ILLUSTRATE THE
NATURE OF THE CRIME. SINCE INYO
COUNTY THREE PER HOUSEHOLD.
THAT THAT 83% OF AM I CAN
AFFORD TO MEDIAN RENTS. SO
THAT'S A SOLIDLY MODERATE
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. BORDERING ON
ALMOST LOW INCOME AND THEN AND
THAT'S FOR A TWO BEDROOM UNIT
AND- GO NOT ONLY GOES QUITE.
YOU NEED TO GET 210028% OF AM I
TO FOR THE MEDIAN RENTS. IF
YOU'RE A THREE PERSON
HOUSEHOLD- AND SOME ADDITIONAL
NUMBERS TO SEVEN OVERLOOKING
OUT IN TERMS OF INCOME SO THING
YOU COUNTY MEDIAN INCOME RIGHT
NOW FOR A THREE PERSON
HOUSEHOLD IS SEVENTY SEVEN
SEVEN THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY. AND THE UPPER LIMIT FOR
A MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLD IS
NOT THREE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
AND IN SAN FRANCISCO IT'S A
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND UNDER
ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS THAT'S
MEDIAN INCOME INTIMATE CISCO.
AND INCOME TOPS OUT OF FORTY
SEVEN THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED.
AND HAVE SOME CONTEXT OF LIKE
HOW PEOPLE ARE MAKING AND- FIVE
AS- INCOME IN. THAT LOT OF
INTEREST FAQS ABOUT WHAT'S
GOING ON I JUST WANT TO GET A
SHOT BECAUSE- I DON'T REALLY
THE HELP HOUSING PARTNERSHIPS.
HARD WORK INTO ALL THAT. TO
REALLY GIVE US THAT'S ALL. IS
CAN AFFORD RENT WHO THREE. SO
DOESN'T THAT THERE'S NO ISSUE
AT ALL MIDDLE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
AND- IN I THINK. IT DOES LOOK
AT CHALLENGES OF MOVING INTO
HOW SHIP YOU KNOW OUR OUR HARD
BECAUSE THERE CAN BE A BIG THE
COST OF A AND THE AVERAGE
MEDIAN RENTS RIGHT SO EVEN IF
YOU'RE- 40% OF YOUR INCOME AND-
COST RENTAL UNIT THAT THE FOR.
TO YOU THAT'S STILL KLAY ISN'T
GET TRANSITION INTO A MUCH
HIGHER COST. AT OF. PEOPLE
AREN'T MOVING RIGHT I'M AND
THEN CONTINUE A IN AFFORDABLE
THAT AND INSTEAD OF MOVING INTO
SHIP IN BEING ABLE TO BUILD
THAT EQUITY WHICH WHICH WE WANT
FOR PEOPLE AND IT DOESN'T TALK
ABOUT RATE HOW FAR PEOPLE ARE
HAVING TO DRIVE TO FIND THAT
MEETING COMMUNITY ACROSS THEIR
COUNTY IT DOESN'T TALK A LOT
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES OF.
FINDING A PLACE WORK. LIVE
ACTUALLY WORKS YOU CAN ACTUALLY
CUT. IT'S AN COST SO BUT I
THINK IT'S JUST IMPORTANT TO
THE CONTEXT THE SCALE. OF
PRICES IN COMMERCIAL. AND WANT
TO KNOW IT IT JUST AND I THINK
IS INTERESTING IN A FULL
CONVERSATION ABOUT MIDDLE
INCOME HOUSING- LOOK WHAT ARE.
THEY TALKING. SO LIKE ME RIGHT
THANK. MIDDLE INCOME CUT A
LEGAL CONTRACT THAT'S THOSE
FOLKS THAT ARE AT ONE TWENTY A
100% AND I THINK WHEN AVERAGE
PERSON. MIDDLE THEY'RE
PROBABLY. REALLY WIDE BAND OF
FOLKS ALL THE WAY FROM VERY LOW
INCOME ALL THE WAY UP TO
PROBABLY. 50% AM I IT'S A MUCH
BROADER SPOTTED PEOPLE SO A LOT
OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE IN THE CAN
BE AN AND ONE INTEREST JEFF
WE'VE SEEN IN CALIFORNIA OF
LATE AS- A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
JUST FIVE YEARS AGO WERE NOT
MODERATE INCOME BEYOND. THE NO
FAULT AS INCOME. IN SOME CASES
VERY LOW INCOME BECAUSE WE'RE
SEEING MEDIAN INCOMES GO UP AS
WE'RE SEEING A LOT OF. IN A LOT
OF MONEY. THAT'S DRYING IT IN
INCOME UP AND WILL SETTLE. TO
THE BOTTOM AND. SO THAT'S
SHIFTING PEOPLE INTO LOWER AND
LOWER INCUMBENTS. SORT OF.
CHALLENGE WE THINK THAT ADDRESS
THE HOUSING. SO THAT'S JUST
SOME OF THE DATA CONTEXT AT ING
AND TO GET IT TO THE SORT OF
THE PACIFIC QUESTION HANNAH
MEET AYE AYE THE REMAINS
REGISTER AYE THERE'S A LOT OF
CHANGES ARENA PROCESS IN LAST
YEAR'S AND WE'RE- SIX HOUSING
ELEMENT CYCLE IN AND- YOU EVER.
THERE READ A NUMBER IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS WHEN YOU.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE YEAH SO AND
THEN THE NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO
THROUGH THEM ALL AND EIGHT
YEARS IF I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO LOOK AND SEE DID
THE CHANGES FROM. A AN AB. ONE
ANOTHER BILL TRULY. COURSE THAT
YOU KNOW THE READ IT DOES
ACTUALLY LOOK AT WHAT IS. IT
EXISTING AND MADE FOR HOUSING
ACROSS THE- LAND. COME IS IN
THERE- BUT I WOULD I DO THINK
THAT THERE'S PROBABLY. HOUSING.
IT'S NOT SO MUCH A SUBSIDY
ISSUE FOR MIDDLE INCOME LIKE WE
CAN PROBABLY FIGURE OUT WAYS TO
PRODUCES UNITS BUT WHAT WE WANT
REALLY IS A BROADER RANGE OF
HOUSING TYPES. STATE WE SHIFTED
FROM OUR CITY IS HAVING A WHOLE
BUNCH OF DIFFERENT TYPE OF
HOUSING UNITS ARE. USED A LOT
OF MULTI FAMILY WE HAD CORRECT
AS WE HAD YOU KNOW BOARDING
HOUSE THEN WE HAD DUPLEXES AND
TRIBALISM FOR PLACES AND NOW
INCREASING THOUGH WE SEE IS
THEIR SINGLE FAMILY. AND
THERE'S HIDING. APARTMENTS A
LOT HAPPENING IN BETWEEN. AND I
THINK ONE THING AND HOW COMMENT
SO. ONE OF THE BIG THE THAT RAN
A NUMBER RIGHT BIG RAN IT'S-
IT'S BROKEN DOWN CITIES HAVE TO
PLAN FOR AND THAT THE ONE OF
THE BIG THINGS I HAVE TO DO
AMONG MANY OTHER. IMPORTANT
THINGS IN THE HOUSE NOT PROCESS
IS YOU HAVE TO SHOW. ONE OF
THEM'S OUT TO COMEDY THAT
NUMBER. TO SHOW THAT YOU CAN
ACCOMMODATE THE LOW IN VERY LOW
INCOME. THAT YOU HAVE TO POINT.
PLEASE ON MULTI FAMILY. BUT
THEN NOT MINE ABOVE MINE YOU
CAN OUT. AT A 100% NUMBER
SINGLE FAMILIES ON SITES. THAT
DOESN'T REALLY. IN A
JURISDICTION THAT'S NOT
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN
SIGNING FOR DUPLEXES IN TRIAL
EXCELLENT FOR PLEXUS CAN TELL
THAT TO HAPPEN SO I THINK.
CONSENT HOUSING ON A LOT OF
THAT. IN THE ABOVE MY SOME
PERCENTAGE THAT SHOULD BE
ALLOCATED TOOK TO SITES ALLOW
MULTI FAMILY MOMENT AT LEAST
FOR SAYS RATE MAYBE HOW MAY BE
TIRED TODAY. BECAUSE THAT'S
GOING TO WRITE. OPPORTUNITIES
WHETHER THE JURISDICTION OR NOT.
BROADER RANGE OF HOUSING
TYPOLOGIES NOT ADDRESS SECTION.
AND FOR PEOPLE LIKE ME IT'S
ACTUALLY IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT THIS HAPPENED IN THE TEXT
OF. BECAUSE THERE'S A BUNCH OF
OTHER THINGS THAT HAPPEN IN
THAT HOUSING ELEMENT PROCESS
AND ONE THING IS WHEN YOU.
PLACE THEM IN TWENTY MINUTES
DECISION ARE YOU GONNA UPS ON
AND WHERE YOU'RE NOT. YEAH IT.
BUT HERE PERSONS OVER IS THIS
GOING TO HELP US AFFIRMATIVELY
FURTHER FOR HOUSING MOUTHFUL OF
ILLEGAL HAVE XIN BUT THAT
EFFECTIVELY SAYS THAT M. NOT
ENOUGH FIRST IS IN. THE STATE.
AT THE END NOT DO THOSE THINGS
DID NOT REPLY NOT DOES BAD
THINGS WE NOW HAVE IN THE PAST
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE THREE SHOWING
YOUR- ACTIVE. UNDO THAT LEGACY.
SYSTEM THAT ADDS THOUGH
ANYTHING CALIFORNIA THE BILL IF
WE REALLY THINK THOSE ZONING
DECISIONS HAPPENING IN THAT
CONTEXT NOW IS REALLY THE
APPROPRIATE PLACE FOR THAT BUT
THAT'S A RECOMMENDATION HAVE
THAT COULD ENABLE US TO REALLY
I THINK MOVE. THE AGENDA YOU'RE
HOPING TO PURSUE FURTHER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LAST
UP ON THIS. THANK NUMBER GLORIA
THANK YOU VERY. THANK YOU TO
THE OTHER MEMBERS PLEDGED TO
FOR BEING I'M BILL FULTON- I'VE
BEEN A URBAN PRACTICE OF
FORMULA FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS
OF FORMER PLANNING DIRECTOR OF
SAN DIEGO FORMER. MAYOR. AN ICE
RIGHT ABOUT LAND USE POLICY
ISSUES FOR PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT REPORT- I JUST WANT
TO MAKE IT A FEW OBSERVATIONS
TO TRY. CONGRESS CAN THINK. THE
OTHERS YOU PANELS HAVE DONE A
GOOD JOB OF BEING OUT ONE OF
YOUR POLICY CHANGES THE
ASSISTANT. OF HAS GONE THANKS
IN LARGE. THE WORK THAT THAT
THE LAST THREE AT THERE'S A
HUGE I THINK IMPLEMENTATION
CHALLENGE FOR BOTH A C. H. CG
AND BUGS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE. IN IN FOR TING OTHER
ARENA. STUFF THE QUESTION AT
HAND IS S. IS ON IT HAD REALLY
IS- SHOULD WE LOOK UP YOU
SHOULD WE DOUBLE EFFORTS IN
EIGHTY ONE TO ONE TWENTY RANGE
DID WE DO ABOVE THE LAW
ALTHOUGH ABOVE THE 120% HUNDRED
YOU KNOW BOB CURTIS THERE'S
PEOPLE MAKE A 100% COME HAS
MONDAY SEPT ELEMENT THAT'S A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT SOUNDS
LIKE A LOT OF MONEY RIGHT UNTIL
YOU TRY TO BUY A HOUSE. SO. TO
SOME WOMEN THIS POINT YEAH I'M
IT'S MY OBSERVATION THAT IN
FACT. THE PRIVATE DEVELOPERS IN
THIS BLOOM AREA REALLY ARE IN
FACT BUILDING TO THE HIGH END
OF THE MARKET THEY'RE NOT
BUILDING IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
MARKET I THINK THERE IS SOME
OPPORTUNITY IF THERE'S A IF
THERE'S AN- DOWNTURN TO SET
THINGS UP SO THE- MORE TO THE
MIDDLE OF THE MARK. AT ALL. GET
TO THAT IN A MINUTE. ON THE
RIGHT IS IT WORTH CREATE OTHER
LAYER IN. YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
GOOD IN THE ABOVE MODERATE
RANGE OF A HUNDRED TWENTY TO
FIFTY OR A HUNDRED TWENTY
HUNDRED SAN AYE THAT'S WORTH
THINKING ABOUT I THINK THAT IS
A POLICY IDEA WORTH CENTERING
THE QUESTION IS I THINK THEN
WHAT DO YOU DO. RIGHT YOU OKAY
FINE YOU HAVE ANOTHER NUMBER
RIGHT IN THE RENO PROCESS YOU
HAVE ANOTHER ANOTHER TARGET TO
HIT. IN THE HOUSING ELEMENT.
WHAT TOOLS DO YOU HAVE IN THE
STATE THIS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
ACTUALLY ENCOURAGE DEVELOPERS.
TARGETS I THINK IT IS PUT. THAT
IN A MINUTE. I THINK. TO THE
CRITICAL QUESTION I THINK IS
NOT NECESSARILY. IS THERE
TARGET IN THE RENO WITH AS I
SAY IS WORTH CONSIDERING BUT
THEN WHAT TOOL DOES THE STATE
AT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THIS STUFF ACTUALLY
GETS BUILT BECAUSE IN THE END
AS YOU ALL SAID AT DINNER TIME
THE QUESTION HERE IS NOT HOW TO
PLAY I DID GO TO CREATE A GOOD
PLAN EVEN THOUGH THAT'S WHAT
TALKING AND THEY TAUGHT ME IN
SCHOOL IT'S HOW DO YOU. MORE
HAPPENING. ASPECTS IS THE
SECOND ONE WHICH. TING TYPE A
SECOND ONE IS THE OVERALL
PLYWOOD WHICH- WHICH I THINK IT
CAME UP EARLIER IS THE QUESTION
OF TENURE WHAT TENURE WE SHOULD.
ARE WE SHOOTING FOR MORE ARE WE
SHOOTING FOR RENTAL HOUSING AND
FINALLY FINANCING HOW DO YOU
PAY FOR IT OR HOW DO YOU HELP.
HOW DO YOU HELP IT'S- TENANTS
TENANTS OR HOME OWNERS PAY FOR
IT. GOING THROUGH THOSE VERY
QUICKLY. EACH ON THEIR OWN I
WANT TO MAKE A COUPLE OF POINTS
HI I AGREE WITH ON THE- THAT
REQUIRING FORCING OR OTHERWISE
COURAGE IN OF THE READING
COURAGE IN GEORGIA. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CONSIDER A WIDER
RANGE OF HOUSING TYPE IS A VERY
GOOD IDEA AND SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED IN THE HOUSING
ELEMENT I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
AN EXCELLENT QUESTION THE
EXCELLENT ISSUE. AT THE EXIT
POINT ON THE SUPPLY QUESTION I
THINK YOU ALL SAID IT IS NOT
YOU'VE ALL TALKED A VERY WAS
ABOUT HOW THE. THE BARRIERS ARE
HIGH NEED TO COME DOWN THEY
HAVE DOWN IN MANY WAYS WE'RE
THE WE'RE THAT TENDS TO GO IS
WHERE THAT HAS TENDED TO GO ON
IT GO IS TAKE A BREAK SINCE
ELSEWHERE FOR IN ELEMENT THAT
STILL PRETTY COMPLEX AND I
RELATED TO THIS TOPIC SIMPLE
FOR THIS OP OF A SAID I WAS
HAVE A SET THING THAT. SIMPLE
THANKS A IS ALWAYS REALLY
COMPLICATED. I THINK TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO SIMPLIFY THE
INFILL REQUIREMENTS IS IT IS.
BUT THE LAST TWO POINTS TENURE.
I THINK OTHER THINGS HERE WHAT.
YOU REALLY GOING TO MISS THE
TOUGH QUESTION OF WHAT. IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE IN
THE EIGHTY TO ONE TWENTY ENTER
ONE TWENTY TO ONE FIFTY ONE
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. HOW ARE WE
TRY TO GET THOSE PEOPLE BECOME
HOMEOWNERS IN CALIFORNIA. OR
HAVE WE IT'S THE DISTANCE IT'S
WHERE I HAVE TO BE RENTERS AND
IF THEY ARE PRINTERS HOW DO WE
HELP THEM DO THAT HOW DO WE
HELP THEM STABILIZE AND- IN
RENT AN ILLICIT SO I WOULD
GETTING TO THE- MISSING. ONE OF
THINGS THAT WE- HAVEN'T. PLEASE
LET PAST EXPERIENCE IN AMERICA
IN GETTING MIDDLE INCOME PEOPLE
OR PEOPLE OF RELATIVELY MODEST
MEANS INTO HOUSING. OR IT TOO
TICKLING AND OWNERSHIP HOUSING.
FOR EXAMPLE THE POSTWAR
EXPERIENCE HAS SOME RELEVANCE
NOT A LOT OF RELEVANT BECAUSE
THAT WAS LAND OF RICH LAND RICH
CHEAP LAND BUT- WHAT THE
FEATHER IN AT THAT POINT DID DO
WAS CRY S. GREASE OF FINANCE
PROGRAMS THAT ALLOWED. HOMER
HOMEOWNERS TO BUY WITH VERY
VERY LOW BY IN BECAUSE OF YOU
KNOW IT'S VERY VERY LOW.
PAYMENT AND I THINK YOU THINK
ABOUT MIDDLE TRYING TO MAKE
MIDDLE INCOME HOUSING WORK AND
MAKE IT WORK FOR THE PEOPLE OF
THOSE INCOMES. MIGHT WANT TO
THINK ABOUT THERE ARE THE ARE
THE IS THERE SOME OF FINANCING
PROGRAM. CAN UNDERTAKE OR
EXPAND. THAT WOULD THAT WOULD
EXPECT THE BILL OF THE OF
MIDDLE INCOME READY TO GET INTO
A AN EXPENSIVE. ON THE COSTA
LOT OF MONEY BUT WE ON PAYMENT
AND SO THAT. THE SYSTEM THE
OTHER THING I WOULD SAY.
QUESTION OF WHETHER OR NOT.
INCOME RESIDENTS AS RENTERS IS
TO LOOK AT AMONG THE MODEL THAT
WE HAVE SEEN IN OTHER STATES-
PARTICULARLY PROBABLY THE
PROBABLY THE MOST FAMOUS IN THE
MOST EXPENSIVE MIDDLE INCOME
RENTAL HOUSING PROGRAM IN
AMERICA ST. HELLO MY PROGRAM IN
NEW YORK- WHICH WAS A NINETEEN
SEVENTIES EIGHTIES YOUR PROGRAM
A WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY PROVIDED
DEVELOPERS THE GUARANTEED
RETURN IN EXCHANGE FOR BUILDING
MIDDLE INCOME RENTAL OF
PROJECTS- FOR A COUPLE HUNDRED
THOUSAND UNITS. NEW YORK CITY
UNDER MANY ALLAMA. AS I SAY
THAT WAS A RENTAL PROGRAM THAT
MIGHT NOT BE WHAT YOU WANT ONE
FOCUS ON BUT IT MAY BE THIS
POINT. BUT I THINK THE VERY
RELEVANT POINT ABOUT SELAMA IT
AND SIMILAR THREE ENGUERRAND
RETURNS FOR DEVELOPERS. THAT IN
A BULL MARKET. DEVELOPERS MAY
NOT BE SO INTERESTED IN THAT
BUT BUT IN A BUST MARKET AND I
REMEMBER BEING A MAYOR DURING
THE DURING THE LAST BUST AND
WATCHING ALL OF OUR PROJECTS
ALL OVER PRO PROJECTS TO. NIGHT
YOU CAN MAKE THOSE SAME
DEVELOPERS INTERESTED IN A
DIFFERENT MARKETS. IF YOU
PROVIDE THEM SOME SOME
FINANCING INCOME STABILITY SO
AS I SAY I THINK THE THOSE ARE
FOR DIFFERENT ISSUE TYPE SUPPLY
YOU'RE IN FINANCING AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO TALK ABOUT MORE ABOUT
THOSE THANKS VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLY BURGLAR. THANK YOU
SIR. THANK YOU ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS I WILL TRY TO MEMBERS
THE BEFORE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS. IF ANYONE WANTS A-
HE WOULD BE SHOT SENATOR GO FOR
PLEASED THAT A WINNER. MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU THAT WAS ALL.
THE I. HELPFUL AND I. WANT TO
ASSIST BECAUSE I- I WAS
CRITICAL OF THEM NOW I
COMPLIMENT THEM OPPORTUNITY I
CAN PUBLIC I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE SCOTT AG- FOR
REALLY DOING THE RIGHT THING-
SCOTT I COULD TRY TO PROPOSE
ONLY FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
UNITS SHE CAME BACK. THREE NINE
THANKS TO A SB TO. BE SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY ONE YES. NUMBER. THE
BILL AND UPS GUY. THAT NUMBER
AND ACCEPTED IT AND THEN
THOUGHT ABOUT MAYBE PUSHING A
LOT OF THE DOG INTO THE KITCHEN
OF ALLEN INLAND EMPIRE AND THEN
THOUGHT BETTER OF IT AND I.
MAYOR AND CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS
OF LA IN. AND SCOTT A GOOD
DOCTOR A STRONG MAN AND I BE
I'D SHALL. SB THIRTY WILL HELP
BECAUSE- WITH THREE THOUSAND
UNITS HE SAID LIKE HUNDRED IN
SANTA MONICA AS A BILL HAVE
HUGE INCREASES- IT WAS A BIG
SUPPORTERS OF CHOICES TO SCOTT
FOR DOING THAT NO IT BAG IS
GOING TO I'M. TO EVEN BETTER
AND OUR OKAY. ONE TALK ABOUT IN
A BOOK REMEMBER FRIEDMAN. I
MENTIONED ABOUT BUILDING BY AN
I THINK SOMETIME HE- VIEW THIS
HOUSING AND VERY EASY HELPING
FORCES LOOK TO YOU LUXURY AND
ALL OF. WHAT'S LUXURY BECAUSE
EXPENSE SEVEN IS EXPENSIVE IT
IS NOT OFTEN BECAUSE THE SAME
PEOPLE CALLING A LUXURY HOUSING
STOPPED HOUSING FOR ANY. SO YES
THERE IS DEVELOP THERE ARE IS
TO HAS CLEARLY LUXURY WITH.
EVERY POSSIBLE AMEND THE MORE
PERSON AND. IS THERE ARE A-
MYSTERY THAT IS THE JURY CONDO.
I LOOK AT MY OLD ISRAEL THIS
RECENT UPPER MARK A LOT OF THE
APARTMENT BUILDINGS THAT ARE
BUILT THERE SURE IT'S NEW
CONSTRUCTION SO IT'S MORE
EXPENSIVE THERE'S NOTHING FANCY
ABOUT IT IS HOUSING THAT IS
REALLY EXPENSIVE. SO IT'S LIKE
IF YOU GO AND RENT A HUNDRED
YEAR OLD FLAT INSTANCES GO AN
OLD ACCORDION THAT'S I EVEN NOT
GREAT SHAPE IT MIGHT COST YOU
THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS A MONTH TO
WRITE. BECAUSE IT'S A LUXURIOUS
BUT IT'S. AIR SOME EXTENSIVE
FAMILY HOMES. SELLING FOR TWO
MILLION DOLLARS WHATEVER
THEY'RE SELLING FOR HELLO FOR A
TEN. A SINGLE HOME OUT OF NOT.
BECAUSE IT SCARES AND EXPENSIVE
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN WHAT IT THE
HIGH END LUXURY WHICH ARE SOME
OF THAT BUT WHAT'S AND SEVEN
EVERYTHING. A HUNDRED YEARS OLD
OR SIX OLD IT'S ALL EXTRA AS IS
NOT ENOUGH OF IT. AND ARE YOU
FOR DEVELOPER BECAUSE WE MAKE
IT. LONG AND EXPENSIVE TO
ACTUALLY LEARN ANYTHING YOU
KNOW THERE ARE THERE COULD BE
AN INCENTIVE TO GO MORE TOWARDS
THE HIRING BECAUSE THAT'S ALL.
AND I FIGURE FOR ABLE TO BRING
CALL ON A LOT OF WAYS. WE CAN.
THANK YOU. THIS CHAIRMAN I WAS
TRYING TO LISTEN CAREFULLY
DOLLARS WANTED ASK I KNOW DOES
NOT WAS MOST RAP RENO BUT- DO
ANY OF YOU HAVE KILLER POLICY
PROPOSALS ON WHAT WE OUGHT TO
DO TO THIS SO CALLED MISSING
WORKING CLASS. HOUSE NOT SURE I.
THEY HER REFLECTIONS IN STATE
BUT I. ROLL AM I CORRECT YOUR
ANYTHING PARTICULAR THAT ACTUAL
FOR US. AT THE RISK OF THE LAST.
BUT IF YOU COULD SIMPLIFY IT
AGAIN BECAUSE I THINK WHAT YOU
SAY IDEA WAS WE REALLY CONTINUE
TO FOCUS ON THE FORMAL SIDE.
BECAUSE THE- CLASS AND WORKING
CLASS NUMBER SIR OR SO MUCH
SMALLER THAT WAS. TO HEAR WHAT
YOU SAID THE ONE THE ONE
CONCRETE SUGGESTION I HAVE IS
THAT I THINK IN THE SITE TO
MENTOR AND. I'M AS I WAS SAYING
ALL ALONE THE VERY LOW INCOME
NUMBER HAVE TO GET ALLOCATED TO
MULTI FAMILY SITES. RIGHT BUT
THEN YOU CAN PUT A HIGH RISK
MODERN YOU'RE BOTH RIGHT ON.
THAT SCHEDULE WITH. ALLOW BURKE
HI. MEANT WHETHER IT'S FOR
PLACES ARE FRANKLY MARK.
APARTMENTS I GET A BROADER
RANGE OF HOUSING TYPES I'M
ESPECIALLY THE BIG GREEN IN
NUMBERS ON A LOT OF. THINGS
MUCH BIGGER NUMBERS AND THAT
KIND OF SHIFT WILL. YOU KNOW IN
ADDITION. TO THE ZONING GONNA
HOW COME TO THOSE NUMBERS THAT
THAT'S. YOU KNOW EIGHT ALL
CONSTANTLY WORRIED ABOUT
DISPLACEMENT AND IT WILL. THAT
ARE ATTRACTIVE TO BRING IN NEW
DEVELOPMENT OF PLACES WHERE MY
CLIENTS LIVE NOW GREAT MY LOW
INCOME PEOPLE OF COLOR. I WANT
TO BE ABLE TO STAY IN THE. THEM
TO BE ABLE TO LIVE IN
EXCLUSION. IF THEY WANT. WHICH
THEY CAN'T BUT IT. I'M PROCESS
IF WE MAKE THOSE ON HOW SAYS IT
ALSO. AN ANALYSIS BY IMPORTANT
WHICH IS WHY I LIKE THE IDEA OF
DOING IT THERE. THANK YOU.
OTHER I AGREE WITH THAT IS IT
IDEA I THINK. IN MY REFLECT
THIS WHAT'S THAT I THINK THERE
IS ROOM FOR SOME KIND OF
COMFORT. THAT NECESSARILY
INVOLVE. THAT PASTORE DEEP'S
CITY YOU DON'T KEEP WITH THE
FOR LOW INCOME WHAT MIGHT MAKE
IT EASIER UP. WERE ALL INCOME
TO GET TO THE HOT DOG AND
ALTHOUGH I DON'T HAVE A VERY
SPECIFIC IDEA THAT RIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'D BE HAPPY.
PLUS FOR YOU I WOULD LOVE YOU.
LAST COUPLE YEARS I. WOULD HAVE
BOUGHT A PROPERTY TAX EXCLUSION
FOR. A DIFFERENT. HAD COME TO
US FOR THE. PERCENT MIA TO YOUR
POINT BECAUSE. IT'S **** THESE
DON'T FOR OTHER. IS IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THAT SUBSIDY WOULD BE IN THE
TRADE OFFS WITH LOW INCOME
AFFORDABLE IS HARD SO I'M
ALMOST TO THE POINT HAVING
TRIED THAT A COUPLE TIMES
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE AS MUCH UP
TAKE FOR THAT THAT. AYE AYE MAY
I BE HEARD ON ORDER. A PROPOSED
OUT OKAY. QUESTION FROM ARMS
THING IN MELINDA'S. POWER POINT
AND JUST A QUESTION OF. HOW
THIS ACTUALLY WORKS ON THE
GROUND. THE YOUR ASSERTIONS ARE
SUPPOSED TO TAKE THEIR HOUSING
GRAHAM SO YOU MENTION YOUR WAS
REMOVING IN MITIGATING BARRIERS
TO DEVELOPMENT AND I WONDER
BESIDES BUT ENTIRE CITY. BEING
STE BECAUSE THEY HAVE AN
OPENING I COME TO THE HAVE
SOARED ANORA PLANNED DO. LOOK
WE GET ABOUT THE WAY THAT. IT
SHOULD NOT HAVE AN APPROVED
HOUSING. AND I'LL JUST I'LL
THROW OUT A SAMPLE I CALLED FOR
ME. BUT I DID THREE BILLS ABOUT
EIGHTY ACTION LAST YEAR I
HAPPEN TO LIVE IN A CITY. WHERE
I. IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD SINGLE
FAMILY NEIGHBORHOOD WITH VERY
LARGE LOTS BECAUSE MY CITY
REQUIRES THAT EVERY STANDALONE
EIGHTY YOU AFTER. ON SITE. NO
PART IN ANY OF THESE. ON THIS
PURPOSEFULLY. AND HE NOTHING
FROM EUROPE OR AGENCY THAT
PUSHES BACK DAHLE ON CITIES AND
ASKING THEM TO JUSTIFY AN
ORDINANCE THAT THAT YOU KNOW IS
CLEARLY MEANT. COURAGE AND BY
THE WAY IN THIS GAME NEIGHBOR.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A 40% LIVE
LANDSCAPING REQUIREMENT FOR
FRONT SETBACKS SO JUST TO YOU.
IT WAS. SO HOW. YES SO THERE
ARE TWO DIFFERENT TIMES IN
WHICH HE- KIND OF TAKE A LOOK
AT ANY ISSUES SAYS- FIRST IS
AND THE REVIEW OF THE HOUSING
ELEMENT WHICH IT COMES ONCE
EVERY EIGHT YEAR AND AT IS ON
THAT TIME FRAME SO IT WILL TAKE
A LOOK AT SOME OF THE HOUSING
ELEMENT ABOUT REMOVING.
BARRIERS I AM LOOKING FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT. TING WHAT ARE THEY
EIGHTIES ENTER WESLEY GIVEN ALL
THE LAWS AND- AT AT WHAT NOT.
MY DEAR. EXCEPT FOR MULTI IN A
MULTI FAMILIES AND THINGS LIKE
THAT AND WHAT THE STATUTES AS
IS THAT THERE'S SOMETHING
IDENTIFIED THEN YOU HAVE A
PROGRAM TO REMOVE THEM AND
MITIGATE- WHICH MEANS WE WILL
LOOK FOR A PROGRAM SUCH AS- IN
CYCLE MOBILE OF CONDITIONAL USE
PERMITS FOR MULTICAST. AND
MULTI FAMILIES OUT. VIEW STAGE
RIGHT AND SO THAT IS. BECAUSE
IT'S NOT ONLY ONCE EVERY EIGHT
YEARS THAT WE TAKE A LOOK.
EIGHTY SEVEN TWO WE HAVE THE
NEW FORSMAN THORIUM AND HOUSE
WE PROVIDED SOME TECHNICAL.
INSTITUTE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OF
THEM IN THE DECISION MAKING.
MORE TEETH NOT SO WITH STANDING
UP. ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY AND
THEN ALSO WITH THE NEED TO
LEGISLATE ASKED WE HAVE FORTY
AROUND UP LOOKING. EIGHTY TWO
ORDINANCES. AND BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE FINDINGS AND PER TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. WE HAVE THAT.
WE GET ON A COMPLAINT BASIS
RIGHT NOW THROUGH OUR OUR
WEBSITE. INFORMATION ABOUT
ISSUES AT OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE. DEVELOPERS ARE SAYING THAT
THEY'RE TRYING. TO THAT PROP US
EVEN QUESTIONS FROM LOW BERMAN
IMPLEMENTS PIECES OF LAW AND WE
PROVIDE FIRST. LET THOSE WE
HAVE IT AS A KIND OF IT. ANTI
PROCESS WE START WITH TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND THEN- FINDINGS
AND THEN FROM. EVENTUALLY GET
TO THE WE'VE BEEN THIS YEAR
THROUGH A LOT OF OUR WORK
AROUND THIS ISSUE THAT. THE
TIME WILL WE PROVIDED. THINGS
SEEM TO OUT WELL- AND IF NOT
THEY WERE GOING CONTINUE TO.
THE REQUEST. AND DO THAT
INVESTIGATION WORK AND IT DOES
TAKE SOME STOP YOU BECAUSE I
IT'S ONE THING TO DO. BARRIERS
AT CITY YOU ALWAYS USE TO STOP
ABOUT AND THOUGHT THAT ARE
WITHIN THEIR OWN. SEEN THAT DO
THAT. BUT WHEN THEY'RE
THEMSELVES BECAUSE- WITH WITH
YOU HAVE NO ENFORCEMENT
JURISTIC MEAN THESE HAVE
RIGHTFULLY ADOPTED CODES THAT.
WILL SLIP TOP I'LL MAKE
EVERYTHING YOU'VE JUST SAID
DOESN'T APPLY BECAUSE THERE'S
NO COMPLAINING TO THE THEIR
FOLLOWING THEIR OWN RULES WHAT
I'M SAYING IS THAT THESE ARE
PUTTING BARRIERS UP ON PURPOSE.
ALL MANNERS OF HOUSING- AND YOU
KNOW THAT'S VERY DIFFERENT THAN
THE COMPLETE BUT OCCASIONALLY
FROM DEVELOPERS WERE THERE
FOLLOWING THEIR OWN RULES
THEY'RE ASKING FOR- MEDICATIONS
AFTER PROPOSED HAPPENED GIVE
AND YOU KNOW THINGS LIKE THAT
DIFFERENT STORY I'M- SAYING
THAT YOU MAYBE THINK A LITTLE.
BIT MORE BROADLY. THIS IS EVEN.
IF YOU TO. TELLING YOU THAT THE
PRETTY. I WAS HAS VERY SIMILAR
ORDINANCES AND- WE'RE DOING IT
ON PURPOSE TO STOP BUILDING OF
AT AND OTHER TYPES OF HOUSING
AND THEY MAKE A DOT ALL THE
READ THE NUMBERS THEY WANT BUT
WHEN THEIR OWN CODES MAKE IT.
PROHIBITIVELY X. FOR. I DO YOU
FOR INSTANCE PEOPLE ARE. SO
JUST THROW OUT. THIS IS
FRIEDMAN I'LL TRY TO BE
EFFICIENT I KNOW IT NUMBER
JORDAN YOU YOU MENTIONED EMBARK
ON- THAT I CALLED PREVENT TALK
ABOUT BASED THESE LAWS PASSED
RECENTLY IN THE DISCUSSION AT
YOUR BOARD LEVEL WHAT DO YOU
SEEN IN TERMS OF DISCUSSION I
KNOW THAT INDIGO HAS BEEN
PAYING BACK HOME THE DIFFERENT
PROCESS. I'M IN OFFICES WIENER
VISIONS THE FACT THAT HE'S A
BIG THINGS FOR ME WHAT. KIND.
OF QUESTIONS ARE. THE MEASURE
LOCAL WANTED. SURE I'M- WE ARE-
EARLY ON AND DOES THAT WE
HAVEN'T REALLY BEEN HAVING
CONVERSATIONS AT THE BOARD
LEVEL BUT- YET BUT WE HAVE BEEN
DOING SO FOR OUR- HAVING A LOT
A LOT LIKE THE OFFICIALS AND
I'M REPRESENTATIVES FROM A-
BUNCH OF DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
AROUND. THE COMMUNITY HE
TRANSFERRED IN. THERE I AM IN
WHAT WE CALL THE HOUSING THAT
BUDGET COMMITTEE ON MEETING TO
TALK ABOUT ONE TO GET OUR
NUMBER FROM EACH C. D. HOW ARE
WE GOING TO DISTRIBUTE IT
ACROSS THE REGION AND- WHAT
WE'VE DONE IN THE PAST THAT I
THINK WILL BE MORE PROBABLY
ROBUST THIS TIME. ROUND LOOK I.
LOOK AT WHAT THE JOBS HOUSING
CONNECTION PEACE IS GOING TO BE
ANYTHING THAT WE'VE DONE OUT
LAST TIME AROUND WHEN HE TRIED
TO. I TRIED TO GIVEN. I IT
NUMBERS UP SO GIVING HIGHER
AFFORDABLE HOUSING NUMBERS TO
JURISDICTIONS THAT HIGHER
NUMBERS OF LOCAL JOBS. THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'VE DONE IN THE
PAST I THINK THAT THERE MIGHT
BE AN OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT
CAN WE STRENGTHEN NOT ON. TIME
AROUND SO YOU KNOW VERGE L.
REALLY IN THE EARLY STAGES. I
ALSO LIKE TO SAY IS THAT BILL
TALKED ABOUT. I THINK WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT. I'M HOW CAN WE
TRY TO ADDRESS SOME PORTABILITY
FOR MIDDLE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
ALSO IN THE LOOKING AT. TING
BARRIERS PRODUCTION FOR ALL
TYPES OF HOUSING CAN HELP AT
THAT MIDDLE AND PEACE AND- A
LOT OF THE WILL HAVE FRUIT.
GUYS HAVE ALREADY TAKEN SOME
PRETTY AMAZING ACTION ON ON A
BIG THIS IS THE COST AND SO BIG
THIS IS THE AFFORDABLE
SUBSIDIES. NUMBER OF BILLS THAT
ARE THAT ARE. TO HAVE BEEN TO
EUROPE. I'M ANY OTHER PIECES
AROUND. GETTING HOUSING
PRODUCTION TO GO FASTER. SOME
OF THE. LOOKING AT THROUGH
MINISTERIAL- APPROACH THERE ARE
A LOT OF DIFFERENT C. GREG'S
ACTIONS TO SUPPORT AND FELL OUT
WHICH IS THE TYPE OF MAN IS
LOCATION EFFICIENT I CAN ALSO
HELP ADDRESS THE HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION AFFORDABILITY
ORANGE WHICH REALLY THOSE ARE
THE TWO BIGGEST PIECES OF. MOST
HOUSEHOLDS. I'M AT BUT RIGHT
NOW SEE THE STREAM. ROBERT WHO
HAVE BEEN. IS THAT BECAUSE IT'S
SO COMPLICATED ON THE SHORE
THAT THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE
THE CASE THAT THERE IS ACTUALLY
YOU KNOW SUBJECT TO EXPIRE IS
EASY WITH STREAMLINED- FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE GONNA OPEN TO
LITIGATION. JUST GONNA GO
THROUGH. STATUS ALL WHERE IN.
YOU KNOW OUR PEACE. IF YOU'RE
DRESSING BILLS COMING UP
BECAUSE IF I SEE. TWO MORE
QUESTIONS AND- IF ANY OF YOU
DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER TO THAT
SO IT'S. THERE IS NOT CALLED ME
UP. DOMINO'S FORTY TO GO A KIND
OF THING UP BIT OF A CONSPIRACY
THEORY THAT WE- ACTUALLY WE'RE
THERE'S ENOUGH MAKING UNITS TO
US FOR INSTANCE THE HOUSE READY
THAT THERE'S REALLY NO HOUSING
PRICE CRISIS THAT THIS IS A-
MANUFACTURER THAT PEOPLE ARE
JUST- BUILDING THINGS AND
HOLDING THEM FAKE AND ARE.
HOLDING ON A UNIT CAN AND
THEIR- PURPOSE EITHER BECAUSE
THEY JUST DON'T WANT YOU KNOW
THE MOST IS WHAT THE TIMES YOU
KNOW ARGUED THERE. IT'S MORE
AFFAIRS THAT IS TRYING TO DRIVE
A BY. I AM ALWAYS BE SOME
BREAKING IT IS ME MAYBE ON THEM
DON'T LIVE THERE YEAR ROUND YES.
IT'S THAT AREN'T READY YET. THE
NUMBER SOMETHING LIKE THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND IT'S AN ANY TIME
ARE INTO COULD BE RENTED THAT
ARE YOU CONSIDER READY TO TOWN
AND WHAT IF ANY. I'VE SEEN. DO
YOU THINK I MEAN COUNTY IS.
PEOPLE COURT SO DO YOU THINK
THAT THIS REALLY ISN'T A FACTOR.
PRESS TO MAKE IT A SURE WE ARE
PEOPLE AGO FOREIGN LA TO SAY
THAT WE SHOULDN'T BE BUILDING
AND ANGER NO HOPPING CRISIS
THERE'S NO LACK SUPPLY I IT'S
ALL JUST. VACANCIES. KICK IT
OFF. A PRETTY VACANCY RATE
AMONG A LOT OF THE TRUE LUXURY
ANNONCES ENTERTAINER WAS
TALKING ABOUT OUR LIVES GET
SNAPPED UP BY FORTY TWO IT'S
REALLY TRULY DISSONANT. AND
THEY DON'T NEED TO RUN TODAY.
BUT I WOULDN'T SAY THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU SEE PLAYING
OUT OF EVERY SINGLE COMMUNITY
ON THE STATE IT'S REALLY IN
THOSE. HOT MARKETS THAT ARE. SO
EXAMINE CISCO LA PLACES THE-
GLOBAL CITIES. I'M AT THINK ONE
WAY TO DEAL WITH DODD WHICH
WE'VE SEEN IN VANCOUVER HAVE
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS WITH HIS
IMPOSING A TAX. THAT MEANS THAT.
AND QUITE SUCCESSFUL DAY AND SO.
HAVE A PROPOSAL FOR CÁC I
THINK IT WOULD TAKE UP THOUGHT
ABOUT WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE
ON A STATEWIDE BASIS IT FEELS
IN A LOT OF WEIGHTS LIKE IT'S
SOMETHING THAT. A PARTICULAR TO
A BIGGER MARKET AND IS TO BE. A
LITTLE TOO BUT PERHAPS THERE'S
A WAY TO DO IT. I THINK WE DO
HAVE A ONE CITY RIGHT BUT IT IS
KIND OF THAT CITY THAT WILL
CITY MUCH LIKE THE PLAGUE SAME.
RATES AMONG THE SET OF UNIT SO
I THINK IT MEANS THAT THERE IS
A HOUSING CRISIS WE KNOW WE'RE
SHORT. UNITS IN THE STATE
DRAMATICALLY SO YOU SEE THAT
BUT IT'S NOT WHAT I HEAR FROM.
CONSTITUENTS YOU KNOW WE KNOW.
THE NARRATIVE THE DOUBT THEIR
COMPUTER ONE MORE THING IN
THERE. THEY WILL YOU KNOW CUT
BONTA DISCARDED AND WE HEAR IT
FROM HOW BECAUSE. THEIR WORK
BUT DISPLACEMENT AND THEN ALSO
HAVE PIPPIN SEE ABSOLUTELY NO
SO MY PROBLEM YEAH THIS IS ALL
A BIG LIE IT'S ONLY. SHIRTS SO.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT. YEAH. WAS ONE
AND I AM IS A CASUALLY IN I
THINK A PART OF OUR CHALLENGE
RIDE TALK ABOUT. IT IS THAT
PROTECTIONS FOR. PEOPLE I AM IT
DOT FOR INVESTORS. LOOKS AT A
RABBIT FOR A FULL TO ACTUALLY
IS FOR KIDS AND THEIR GRANDKIDS
ARE MAKING THEMSELVES ON AN-
ANCIENT AND THE TECHNOLOGY
WHICH IS. RIGHT RIGHT DIVERSITY
PRODUCT. SOME VERY INNOVATIVE
STUFF I'VE SEEN ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT I'M THE ONLY MATCHING
I GREW UP WITH BUT SEEMS
RELATIVELY POPULAR TERMS OF
SQUARE FOOTAGE AND THEN IT AND
WHATNOT AND- WE INCENTIVIZE
THAT TO THE. I DON'T KNOW BUT
MAKES POINTS. MAYBE IT TO WRAP
UP. IN THE I'D BE INTERESTED IN
WHAT OWNERSHIP THE CHAIR. THE
LEGISLATIVE SUGGEST BUT. YOU
KNOW MY OFFICES DOORS BY. THE
IT. YOU MAY FOR RELIEF FROM
POINT IN THAT AND I APPRECIATE
AND OF MAKING THAT SOMEONE ELSE
IS IN THE TOP. CUSTOM. RECALL
ABOUT HOW WE'RE USING. IS
INSTREAM- BUT IF THERE'S A SORT
OF GATE ON THAT I THINK YOU'RE
MAKING A CALL THERE'S A LOT
MORE THAT WE- DOING. ON THAT
ARE SO THE. HERE I THINK THAT I
THINK ONE SOME OTHER THINGS BUT.
BUT OKAY HOUSING. AND THE COST
XIN HIM THE STATE RIGHT NOW
CLEAR BEST OF CONSTRUCTION
LABOR. PART OF THAT. SEEM TO ME
THAT ONE OF THE MOST
CONSTRUCTIVE THING SO I'M NOT
IN THIS THE STATE IS A WORK FOR
IT BOB AND PROGRAMS TO
ENCOURAGE A- OF. CONSTRUCT IS
THAT EVERYBODY. I AND I THINK
THAT THAT WOULD BECAUSE I THINK
YOU'VE GOT AN UPPER LIP
PRODUCTION RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF
CONSTRUCTION LABOR RIGHT AT
THAT THAT'S ONE THING. ANOTHER
POINT WHICH UP ABOUT
UNFORTUNATELY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN DOES NOT YOUR POINT
BUT BUT GHOST OF THE NEW
CONSTRUCTION IN NEW AREAS. IS
ONE OBSERVATION I WOULD MAKE IS
A LAND USE PLAN ARE HAVING SAY
OVER THE YEARS AS- TELL
TYPICALLY WANT TO DEVELOP ON
PRESS COME SIT ALONE PROCESS.
AS ALL OF YOU KNOW- DID GET THE
DENSITY GETS KNOCKED DOWN IN
THE PROCESS EIGHT YOU YOU'VE
ALL SEEN THAT. I'M AN EXCEPTION
TO THAT IT REALLY WHEN THERE IS
A SPECIFIC AND PLANTS- WHEN
THERE IS A FOR ALTHOUGH THAT
CAN BE. A TIME. I MEAN FOR AN
EXPENSIVE FRONTAL SAYS. NEVER
THE LESS THE RESEARCH DIED. YES
THAT IS A THIS OFTENTIMES
THERE'S A TRUCK GOOD SIGNAL IF
YOU ARE AT AND YOU BE ABOUT A
1100% YOU DON'T SEE ANY KNOCKED
DOWN THE CITY YOU SEE A 1100%
APPROVAL RATE. AND FOR
CALIFORNIA PLANET REPORT
WORKING RIGHT NOW ON AN ARTICLE
ABOUT ABOUT THE- HELLO OF
EVIDENCE. IN EL SERENO WHICH
HAS BEEN A PRETTY GOOD EXAMPLE.
SO. I WOULD SEE BEYOND
REGULATION BEYOND FUNDING. OF
THE OF THE WORK FORCE
DEVELOPING FOR CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS. THE USE IN THE RIGHT
SITUATION OF SPECIFIC PLANS
LAID THE GROUND AND GET
EVERYTHING SET UP AHEAD OF TIME
SO THEY WIND UP IN THAT
KNOCKDOWN DRAG. COME AT UPS. AT
THE PROJECT LEVEL. THANK YOU
SIR AND I WOULD JUST BEYOND FOR
THE BEYOND THE SESSION NEW
LEGISLATION WHICH TYPICALLY
IT'S LIKE ME CAN BE HELPFUL FOR
THE EVENT OUT AND HE'S OUT I
THINK ONE OF THE. IS OVERSIGHT-
AND I THINK THERE'S BEEN A BIT
OF A GREAT DEAL JUST PLACE
THIRTY TODAY'S. HOW DOES IT IS
HARD AS THE MEAN IT. WAS GONE
AND THAT THINGS HAVEN'T PLAYED
IT OUT. GIVEN THAT WE HAD BOTH
A HOUSING CHAIRS. TODAY IN SOME
TIME TO GO BACK AND LOOK AND
SEE YOU KNOW IT IS A THE
ACTIVITIES. OF OUR WE GAUGING
WITH AG'S OFFICE TO FOLLOW ON
AND MAKE. THEIR FAIR PART HOW
THE WHOLE AGENCIES IMPLEMENTING
SOME THIS. I'M EVEN IF IT'S IN
PROGRESS B. THINK ABOUT
OFFICIALLY TIME. DEGREES NAY
LOCAL COMMUNITIES UP TO THESE
CHANGES. YES SO THAT WE DON'T
WHEN WE HAVE MIDDLE PORTION. DO
I THINK IT'S WHERE YOU'RE SORT
OF BRINGING UP YOU KNOW RIGHT
NOW I THINK WE ONLY KNOW OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS BY NOT PROVIDING
WHAT THEY WERE PROMISED INTENDS
ITALY ON THE CAN OF WHAT IN THE
ABILITY. TO SOMETHING IN DAHLE
TWELVE I MIGHT FOR THE FACT HI
A UNIT THAT SOMEONE WHO SHOULD
MAKE IT A LOT LESS MONEY HE
SHOULD. BE RENTING A BECAUSE I
CAN FOR THE NEXT ROUND IT'S ON
CONTRIBUTED TO THIS TOWN'S BUT
ALSO THE CHALLENGE RIGHT AND
SO- YOU KNOW- AS WE ARE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT NEXT STEPS
THAT ARE MAYBE SOME OF THE BEST
TIME TO BE USED ON A PROVIDING.
THE OVERSIGHT ASK THE QUESTIONS
FOLLOWING UP WITH. AFTER
UNDERSTOOD. WE DOING. WORKING
IN AND WHAT MORE MAY NEED TO BE
DONE. MANY FOR COMMENTS MADE ON
THE- WE CHECK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOU THIS AFTERNOON.
CHECK THIS. TO OUR PANELISTS.
IN THE AUDIO. AND THE LARRY
WILL BE JOINING US. THE
PRESENTATION AGAIN WILL TAKE-
MAY NEVER QUESTION AFTER THEY
PRESENT WE WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THERE IS A PUBLIC
COURT HERE WAIT FOR THAT SHOULD
MAKE THE TIME UNLESS YOU HAVE A
PRISON CALIFORNIA BE WHO ARE
HERE WITH. IT'S NOT SURPRISING
IN THE LEAST. GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'RE HERE. WELCOME. AIR AND
GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK BETTER
DOES ON ISSUES AROUND HOW OF
FLORIDA. THANK YOU SO MUCH- IN
IN IN THANK YOU ALL FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY. I AM. THE
RESEARCH AT THE TURN CENTER FOR
HOW THE- KLAY. I'M I WANT TO
TALK TO YOU TODAY ABOUT THE
RESEARCH THAT WE'VE DONE AROUND
DEVELOPMENT IS AN- THE- SO. NOT
THIS COMPENSATION WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THESE WERE. DIFFERENT IS
I'M A THING FROM QUIMBY IT IS
TO DO IT HARD. TO IF YOU FELT
THAT CAN PROJECT. IMPACT ALL OF
THE MEDICATION YEAH. SOMETHING
THAT WE STRESSED IN BOTH OF OUR
REPORT AROUND THEM AND FEES AND
IMPACT FEES I FUND VERY
PORTENTS THIS IS THIS IS REALLY
NEAT. TO SUPPORT NEW RESIDENTS.
OUR RESEARCH IS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S TAX INCREASE. ON
IN TO FIND CAMPUS THE WAY. SO
WHAT COUNTIES REPLY ON REVENUE
GREAT EXTENT THAN THEIR. AND
THIS I'M YOU IN TO THE
INTERSECTION HENCE PASTORS AND.
AND ADDITIONAL GEN. CALIFORNIA.
REVENUE PROPERTY TAXES CLIMB
FROM PERCENT OWNED REVENUE IN
NIGHT. SIX AND TWELVE THAT'S
PARTIALLY DUE TO A POLICIES
LIKE PROP THIRTEEN THAT DO
LIMITS ON. PROPERTY TAX THE
LEVY GOVERNMENTS. WHY DO WE
CARE ABOUT THIS AND THIS TRIP
IS CONCERNING BECAUSE OF THE
BODY OF IMPAIR BUTTONS DOES
DRAW A CLOSE LINK BETWEEN.
ISN'T AND HOUSE PRICES. ARE THE
SAM'S LOCAL MARKET THEY MET
HOUSING PRODUCTION PRICING OUT
NEW. FEES ARE TOO HIGH SIX
KILLER LEAVE MORE AFFORDABLE
TYPE PROJECTS MAY NOT PENCIL
OUT ABOUT. SO FIRST REPORT WAS
RELEASED IN NUMBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND IN COURT WE
ACTION. LATER THE FULL AMOUNT.
IS EXCLUDING UTILITY. FOR
PRODUCT OF FAMILY. DEVELOPMENT
EXTRA ACTIONS PROCESS AND WE
FOUND THOSE. SIX THIS IS
POSSIBLE. IN FACT WE FOUND THAT
SOME CASES REPRESENT UP 218% OF
THE MEDIAN FAMILY VALUES MR.
MOST RECENT REPORT ON IMPACT
FEES STEMMED FROM ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT SEVENTY NINE THAT WAS
WRITTEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRACE. OF THE ROAD FOR THAT
STEP WAS TO. THE SYMBOL OF
LOCAL CHARGE YOU TO MEN'S.
SECTION THE SIX THOUSAND SO
THAT'S IN THE NATION. AND AGAIN
THAT'S THE IMPACT YOU AXOLOTL
JUST. IN THAT REPORT JUST
LOOKING AT IMPACT FEES THAT
FALL UNDER THE MEDICATION FEET.
THEY AGAIN VERY WIDELY BY
FICTION THEY CAN BE THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER. WE ALSO
FOUND THAT INSTEAD. ARE YOU. SO
MORE. CONSIDER IN DEVELOPMENT I
THINK THESE THINGS HOW. I THINK
MORE GREEN ABOUT ARE
PRIORITIZING THINGS THINGS
TRANSPORTATION. POURTANT POINT
FOR THIS CONVERSATION. CAN AN
ADVISER TO INCENTIVIZE TYPE. SO
IF YOU LOOKED AT HER DOOR. THEY
ACTUALLY. WHERE BEAR BAIT THING
THERE SAMPLES. HE'S UP FOR YOU
PLACE IS GOING INSANE. THANKS
ABOUT. I'M GOING TO BE PARKS
BOB BROWSE CHARGING IS ON A
SCRIPT. THIS IS AN CENTER IS
THAT SIR. MORE AND THE STATE.
ALSO TURNING LOWER FEES TO
REFLECT THE LESSER IMPACTS THE
GAMBLING DEVELOPMENT
PARTICULARLY WHEN THEY'RE
SITUATED NEAR TRACK. OR WHEN
THEY ARE FOR. I CAN INCENTIVIZE
THOSE AFFORDABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE. JUST A STEP BACK.
AS I KIND OF CLOSE OUT MY TALK.
I WANTED TO MENTION. WHY. SO
THAT WE ARE SEE WHAT COMES UP.
PLOT THAT. TING TOOLS MORE
FAMILY TO HELP AND WE ARE
SEEING LAST NOVEMBER. THE ONE
LARGE METRO AREA. THE SINGLE I
NEED HELP ARE MUCH MORE LIKE TO
BE IN THE TOP. SO IN SUMMARY WE
NEED TO BE USING AS MANY TOOLS
AT OUR DISPOSAL AS POSSIBLE TO
ENCOURAGE MORE OF ONE
SUSTAINABLE HOUSE TYPES
INCLUDING DANCEABLE.
CONSTRUCTION AND WE SHOULD
CONSIDER WAYS TO FUND PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ENSURE THAT
IMPACT THESE DON'T AFFECT THE-
THREE OF NEW CONSTRUCTION AND
TO LEVERAGE. FOR THE MILLIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU HAILING.
GET YOUR NAME ON SSA RIGHT
RANELLIDAE VALLEY. RANELLIDAE
VENTILATING HASN'T RALLY THAT.
VISIT OPEN THEIR LIVE THE SACK
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU BUDGET.
I REALLY HAPPY TO BE HERE AND-
TO CUT SPRINT'S WITH THE
ADOPTED TO DEVELOP AN IMPACT
FEES IN OAKLAND- WHICH IS OFTEN
HELP AS A MODEL OF A GOOD WAY
TO DO IT- SO I'M GONNA SHARE
WITH YOUR EXPERIENCES FOR DOING
THAT AND THEN ALSO ALL.
COLLECTIONS ON WHERE WE THINK
THE STATE COULD HELP. THOUSAND
SIXTEEN HE DID A COP SWEET. IS
THE FOCUS FOR WILL HOUSING
TRANSPORTATION AND CAPITAL
FACILITIES THAT'S THINGS LIKE
HOUSES PARKS AND SO FORTH. 80%
OF THE FEE GOES FOR ABOUT
HOUSING SO THIS IS REALLY A
HOUSING IMPACT FEE PROGRAM.
ARTICLE TEAM THAT DIDN'T
STUDIES- FINANCIAL STABILITY
AND WE HAVE A DOT IS THAT WERE
SMALL AT FIRST THAT GREW OVER
TIME TO GIVE THE MARKET I'M TO.
THE FEES ARE SET BY GEOGRAPHIC
HOME BASED ON. FINANCIAL FEET
BLOODY BECAUSE A GOAL OF THE
PROGRAM IS NOT TO DESCRIPTION
NEW DEVELOPMENT THEY'RE ALSO
SET UP PRINT TYPES BECAUSE-
TYPES DIFFERENT. BILL EIGHTIES
THE TEST WAS VERY TRANSPARENT
WE HAD A WEBSITE WITH ALL THE
RIVER POSTED WE HAD A COMMUNITY
STAKEHOLDER GROUP THAT WAS
COMPRISED OF DEVELOPERS- AT
THIS FOR DIFFERENT- PARTS OF
THE COMMUNITY HOW EXPERTS AND
SO FORTH. THE CONSENSUS ON WHAT
THIS PACKAGE WOULD BE. THE FEES
OF VERY. SOME OF THE CITY THERE
WAS NO FEE AT FIRST. SOME PARTS
OF THE CITY WHERE THE MARKET IS
A. HAVE A MUCH HIGHER FEE.
SINCE THOSE FEES HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED WE HAVE. BEEN A
SLOWDOWN IN DEVELOPMENT IN FACT
IF YOU COMPARE THIS REPAIRS
PRIDE FEET COMPARED TO THE
THREE YEARS AFTER THAT. WE ARE
SUPPLY MARKET RATE HOUSING. I
AM. OAKLAND HAS A THOUSAND
UNITS UNDER. MORE HOUSING IN
ANY CITY IN THE BEAR. IN TERMS
OF MIDDLE INCOME HOUSING. AT
THE RELEVANCY FOR APPROACH. THE
EGGS DID. COME RESTRICTED ON
HOUSING. WE DON'T HAVE TO PAY
THE FEE. SUBSIDY FOR MIDDLE
INCOME HOUSING IS AN EL WILL
USE. AND WE ALSO EXEMPTED
EXCESS. ON THE FEE WHICH IS YOU
KNOW IS A GOOD SOURCE OF ON.
YOU KNOW FOR THE IS. TO ADOPT
THEIR EXPECT. IT WILL OUR
CONTRACT ABOUT A MILLION
DOLLARS THE CONSULTANT TOOK
OVER A YEAR. HAVE THE CAP THE
TO DO THAT BUT A LOT OF SMALLER
THESE ARE NOT GONNA BE ABLE. SO
I THINK WE'RE GONNA. THE BEST
PART. IS THE FOLLOW ON THEY'RE
GONNA NEED HELP ON IT RATHER
THAN EVERY CITY REINVENT THE
WHEEL DOING. ANALYSIS I THINK
THERE'S PROBABLY A ROLE FOR THE
STATE. TO CREATE SOME KIND OF
TAX CALCULATOR BECAUSE REALLY
UP. US AND RENTAL PRICES AND IF
YOU DO THAT ZIP CODE TO SOME BY
GEOGRAPHY STATE THAT'S A LITTLE
JURISDICTIONS TO DO THIS MUCH
MONEY. THANK YOU. JERRY FISHEYE
BY WHITE MALES OF. LARRY YOU
LASSEN PANEL FOR SHORT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I TRY TO BE
JUST MISSION. BEYOND PRESENT
ABOVE CAL'S. THANK NEXT YEAR.
AND WE'VE OVER FIVE THAT
AFFORDABLE HOMES AND CURRENTLY
OWN AND MANAGE OVER 4% HOMES IN
THE NORTH. WE ARE. PERHAPS BEST
KNOWN UNFORTUNATELY YEAH THE
CENTER OF THE BY WILDFIRES
RECENTLY THE KING K. FIRES AND
SO JUST ABOUT I'VE BEEN WORKING
ON HE HAS BEEN RECOVERY AND
REBUILDING. I'M AND. WHEN OUR
HOUSING AND I WANT TO MAYBE
IT'S THE AT THE TABLE HERE TOO
LITTLE BIT ABOUT A SPECIFIC.
KEY STEP. BRING YOU
SPECIFICALLY HOW FEES CAN
IMPACT OBJECTS AND HOW THEY CAN
FASCICULATION PACK WORKS
HOUSING WHICH I THINK WAS TO
FOCUS ON HERE SO I'M GONNA
BRING UP THIS LATE TO. THIS IS-
THIS IS ACTUALLY A CHECK THAT
WE BUILT UP IN A- CALL. IN
SANTA ROSA IT WAS C. B. HOME.
SOLD UP TO PERCENT MY DOWN TO
SIX THEN I AM I WE THINK THAT
CLOSE IT OUT ABOUT YEARS AGO
I'M WE ARE A LITTLE UNUSUAL AS-
A HOUSING COMPANY THAT WE BUILD
PRIMARY BUSINESS IS A CREDIT
PROJECT. MULTI MENTAL.
OWNERSHIP PROJECTS WE ACTUALLY
HAVE TO STRUCTURE. NOW. FOR IT
YOU NEED TO STOP. AFFORDABLE
PRICE AND MARK THIS- STEP
MAKING SEVENTY TWO A 100% I'M
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH ONLY FIRST
TO AVERAGE FOR THIS WE HAD OVER
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY. HE'S
THIRTY FOUR OHMS. WE PRE
QUALIFY TO FORTY PEOPLE MEAN
THERE WENT TO THE CREDIT CHECKS
IN WITH ENDED A LOTTERY AND
SHOWS BEFORE WE HAVE BACK UPS
IN BACKUPS BEHIND THOSE FOLKS
IF THEY DON'T IF THEY DON'T END
UP CLOSING SO THE DEMAND
OBVIOUSLY THEY DON'T NEED TO
TELL YOU THAT BUT IT WAS A
LITTLE OVERWHELMING TESTIMONY
SO I JUST TO THE LEVEL IN THE
EXTENT OF THE DEMAND. IS THERE.
I'M. HERE'S MY LOOK AT THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE BUYING IN IN
THIS PROJECT. THE STATE OF
OFFICE THERE IS. GUARD BUILDERS
MACHINE NOT WRITER UP. IS IT IN
NAPA THERE WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
FEW THAT WERE DISPLACED BY THE
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WILDFIRES THINK OF THE SPREE
FOR HOMES I THINK. TWELVE ARE
ACTUALLY IN MOST AMONG FOREIGN
OR THAT WERE HOMES WERE
DESTROYED IN THE FIRE THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN SERVICES AND TO START
FOR THEM I'M EFFECTIVE SALES
THIS IS FOR. INDY FIVE TELL FOR
THE SAID. MEANING. FOUR WE SET
THESE BASED ON THE AMOUNT OF A
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE THOUSAND-
END UP TO FOUR HUNDRED ANYTHING
ON THE HIGH END. IT SEEMS LIKE
A LOT OF MONEY BUT THEY- A NAP
IS UNDER. AND SO THESE ARE WELL
WELL WELL BELOW MARKET TO SAY
THE LEAST I NEED TO TELL YOU
ALL THAT SO TALKING ABOUT THE
PRICE LIST AS WE WANTED TO
FOCUS ON THE IN STEP DAD FEES
HAVE ON APPROACH LIKE. AS AN IN
WAYS THANK YOU. ITS BUDGET SEE
THAT WHAT I THINK DOING THAT
PEACE PIPE IN PUBLIC SERVICES
THERE AFFECTING FOLKS AND THEIR.
THE LOWER INCOME LEVELS HIGHER
THAN OUR. ARE THE HIGH AND SAID.
THROUGH THE PROJECT THAT YOU
LOOK AT THE RED GROW BUDGET
WHERE CASA WERE COME NINE HAVE
BEEN JUST IT OUT ON FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
THIS OR THIRTEEN HUNDRED SQUARE
FEET BUT. IF OR NO WELL YOU
SAID. EVERY STEP WAS FIRST HOME.
TYPE OF HOME THIS SPECIFIC SAME
MODEL WE HAVE FINISHED IT FIVE
YEARS AGO WE DID IN FRONT OF A
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND SO WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN 20% INCREASE IN
COSTS OVER- THE LAST FOUR YEARS
IN TERMS OF HOW HOW MUCH OF
CLASSES TO BUILD THE SOME SOME
OF THAT IS BECAUSE OF THE. SO
IT JUST BECAUSE OF THE GROWTH
IN CONSTRUCTION- BUT SOME OF IT
IS ALSO BECAUSE OF INCREASED IS
ON THIS. SO WE LOOK AT THE
SOCKS US ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND.
THE END PLEASE AND THAT
PARTICULAR PROJECT. WELL YOU.
TELL THEM THAT. WE REALLY ARE
RIGHT AND WE DO NEW PROJECT UP
TO THAT END UP. AT LOCAL IMPACT
IS THAT WE NEED HELP. I'M AT
YOUR EARLIER YOU CAN GO A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND I'VE
NEVER BEEN IN THAT MARKET AND
I'M NOT SURE I WOULD AT THAT AT
THAT VALUE BUT I'M REALLY WERE
ABOUT. DOLLARS PER HOME IT'S
WHAT WE PAY AND THEN IN
ADDITION TO THAT WERE ALSO
PAYING THE PERMIT FEES THAT YOU
CHARGE AT THE COUNTER SO IN
THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT WE
WERE. KISSING SAYS 70% I AM I
DON'T YOUR 20% IN MY THE
FEATURE ABOUT THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS SO JUST UNDER 10% OF
THE COST IS ACTUALLY GO. USE
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT. ARE YOU
USED IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE
AND SNAP APPS. FIFTY NINE IN
THIS NOW. FIFTY THREE HUNDRED.
THESE ARE GOING TO PAY FOR
PARKS AND RECREATION STREET
IMPROVEMENTS UTILITIES FIREARM
PARAMEDICS AND WATER TODAY- SO
IN A PERMIT FEES ON TOP OF THAT
THAT I SHOULDN'T. TOTAL
POSSIBLE. PLEASE HOLD THESE SO
GOING BACK HERE AGAIN IT'S
BASICALLY TODAY PRETTY IT'S
OVER TELLING BELOW COST IS THIS
ISSUE A DAYS ARE ALL SUBSIDIZED.
YEAH THESE ARE ALL SUBSTANCE.
THANK UP RESTRICT REGULAR YOUR
AGREEMENTS THEY'RE FINISHED. IS
WHAT YOU'RE FEES. THAT PUT THAT
IN EVERY JURISDICTION THAT WE
BUILD EVEN IF WE BELOW MARKET
RATE HOUSES IN FACT THIS IS ONE
OF THE OUT OF HAVING THE
LEGISLATURE IS TO RECOGNIZE THE
FACT THAT THESE ARE BELOW
MARKET IN FACT THIS. PROCESS IS
THAT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
THE WHAT. SUBSIDIZING SO THE
GIVING US MONEY. INDEED
ASSISTANCE TO BASES DOWN AND
THEN IN THEM. IN PART THOSE
MONIES IT'S JUST IT'S JUST.
IT'S A MESSED UP SYSTEM SAY
ITALY'S TO BE. HERE WHICH I
THINK I CAN I'M. I MEAN I. MUCH
TO ADD EXCEPT THE. GOOD FOLKS
THAT ARE IN THIS THESE INCOME
ERROR BY. THAT DOLLAR IMPACT
WHEN WE ARE PROJECTED OUT OF
PASTA MORTGAGE. IT'S GOING TO
COME TO A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS ACTIVITY THAT PERSON IS
PICKING BACK SO IN SOME WAYS
YOU CAN BILL LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ACTUALLY FINANCING THEIR
IMPROVEMENTS IN THIS CASE ON
THE BACKS OF BLOW IT AT LOW LOW
INCOME FOLKS WHO ARE BUYING
THESE HOMES SINCE. THE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS AT THE END. AT
THE END OF THE PROJECT IT ALSO.
SIR ABILITY TO GET A MORTGAGE.
THE ABILITY WE COULD SELL THEM
HOMES TEARS WE HAVE TO GO HIGH.
YEAH MEDIAN COMES IN ORDER TO
REACH FOLKS CAN MORTGAGE INCOME
THAT INCLUDE THE. THERE IS
ABOUT IT'S ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
ABOUT. THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH. IN HOUSING CALL US. THE
PROJECT THAT ARE AS A RESULT OF
THE FEES THAT ARE BEING CHOPPED
UP OBJECT WHICH WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT MAKING SIXTY
THOUSAND HELLO IN THE. PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT HIT THEM SO. IT
MIGHT HAVE ONE PROPOSAL WOULD
BE TO RECOGNIZE THAT WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT WORK FOR HOUSING
THIS IS WHAT I THINK WE'LL- BE
TALKING ABOUT IS EIGHT. 120% I
AM UP. SALE WE DO NOT RENTAL
PRICE ON THE FOR SALE SIGN
WOULD BE GREAT IF WE COULD GET
SOME KIND OF RELIEF. ABILITY TO
LOCAL FEES AND AS A PERCENTAGE
OF OUR TOP LEVEL. SO THAT HAVE
ENTERED A QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
GUYS VERY. I THOUGHT WE CAN GET
THIS THING ABOUT THE SLIDE
BEFORE WITH THE. A TRIAL THAT
IS PRESS POINT DIFFERENCE. SO
ON THE SOFT BECAUSE IT WOULD
YOU HAVE COUNT FOR THIRTY SIX
THOUSAND OF IT. BUT WHAT WE
ESTIMATE. THE COST OF THE SAAB
THREE THOUSAND. ANDERSON OF CAR
SEAT IN AND CATCH SEQUEL-
EXPENSIVE ENTITLEMENT EXPENSE
IS YOU KNOW RELATED WE HAD TO
DO ANY AYE ARE IN THIS THAT
CALIFORNIA THOUSAND DOLLARS
THERE SO A LOT OF THAT COMES
OUT OF THIS OKAY SO IT WILL.
COME PUBLIC CHARGES AND THOSE
ARE LIKE CHARGES BUT THOSE ARE
REGULATORY RIGHT EXPLAINS YEAH.
IS THAT HURDLE TO. RESOLVE THE
REGULATORY EXPENSE. SO YEAH
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN A HOW TO.
THAT SPECIFICALLY BUT I GUESS
IS IT. YES TOM ACOSTA HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND PER UNIT. SO ON
A FIVE THOUSAND. IT'S ABOUT A
QUARTER OF THE LITTLE OVER THE-
PRICE OF THE HOME. OKAY THAT
HELPS. THOUGHT ABOUT. THE
REGULATORY ONES. CASE DO NOT
DOING SO BAD BUT IN IN THE- I
GET IT AND UNDERSTOOD. IT BY
LEYVA MAYES IN SOMEBODY. IN A
SEVERE CURRY IN THE NAPA AREA
AND SHE'S FANTASTIC WITH. STILL
MANY QUESTIONS CAN I GO BACK TO
HEY WE CAN JUST START WITH YOU
ON. THE. I GUESS DAMAGE GAME
THIS ALONE BUT THERE AMERICA
GETTING TO THIS. I'VE HEARD
LATE FEES OAKLAND IS. DON'T UP
TO SEVEN SEVEN. DOESN'T APPLY
TO MIDDLE INCOME. THEIR SET BY
GEOGRAPHY AND WEAKER MARKET
THAT'S WHERE THE REAL ESTATE
MARKET WON'T SUPPORT IT SET
LOWER. ALSO BEFORE THE HOUSING
IS THE EXIT EXAM SO. WHEN HE'S
NOT PAYING IMPACT FEES AND I
GUESS TELL ME IN YOUR- VIEW DID
YOU SEE SIMILAR SORTS OF.
DIFFERENTIALS I MEAN I THEY
MAKE. THIS AN ICE MASON IS A
NEW. FOR ME I DON'T I CAN THINK
OF TO ME FEEDBACK ON THE OR-
YEAH I WAS GONNA SAY THAT'S
VERY MUCH. THIS IS FAIRLY
TYPICALLY WHAT WE- THE- BEING A
VISIBLE DISABILITY PROCESS AND
ACTUALLY IDENTIFYING THE
DIFFERENT HOUSING MARKETS WITH
IN A JURISDICTION AND THEN
ADJUSTING THE FEE RATES WITHIN
THE JURISDICTION BASED ON
FEASIBILITY CONCERNS- THAT
OBVIOUSLY THE BEST PRACTICE BUT
IT IS ALSO EXPENSIVE AND TING-
AND I THINK. SO I THINK THAT
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULD CERTAINLY ELEVATE IN
TERMS OF WHETHER OR NOT WELL
HOUSING DEVELOPERS ARE
TYPICALLY PAYING FEES I THINK
THAT OFTEN WE FIND THAT THE-
IT'S IMPORTANT. HIM IT WILL BE
WHERE BUT OTHER PLEASE. YOU ARE
A. IN SORT OF SOME AND WE CAN
FIX THIS NOW SWEAR ON THE
SQUARE FOOT VERSES IN IT. AND
JOHN. THERE'S NOTHING IN STATE
LAW ABOUT WHAT THAT DECISION
GIVE CHOOSING UNIT OR- RIGHT
NOW. IT DOESN'T FIVE. THE KIND
OF PRODUCTION AND AS WE TALKED
MORE ABOUT DENSITY THAT WOULD
SEEM TO BE SOMETHING WE SHOULD
GIVE SOME. TO OR AT LEAST.
BLAIR IS TALKING ABOUT IT FOR A
FOUR SAYS THAT IN INCENTIVIZE
IN THE CONSTRUCTION OF SUBS.
YEAH. SORT OF YOU KNOW KIND OF
SPIDER IS THE KEY THEIR
INDICATION SYSTEM IS
SITUATIONALLY. YEAH A WAR WHAT
BILL MORE UNITS IS THE PART.
THE CHARGES. WHAT'S GOING ON
FREMONT IN YOUR. I MEAN I SO
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT WE-
REALLY WERE JUST TRYING TO.
SELECT A. I WERE AS IT'S REALLY
TO BE NEGATIVE. PROCESS STATE.
COUNTIES THEY HAVE DIFFERENT
FUNDING PRIOR AND YOU KNOW NOT
NECESSARILY TO SPECIFY OUT
FREMONT SPECIFICALLY TO SAY
LIKE ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE SEEING A WIDE
VARIATION IN COSTS TO THAT I
SAY THE WORST OF TO AND THAT
WAS THE ESSENCE A REGION A
JUDGMENT ON THAT BUT THEY THAT
THE HIGHEST IT IS. TIED TO THE
SAMPLE YOU. LIKE THAT BUT IT'S.
AND WITH IT HERE ON THE OTHER
END I RECOGNIZE THE. CONSENSUS
BUT IT KIND OF THE POINT NEXUS
STUDIES MY EXPERIENCE AS A
LOCAL ARTIST- IT FEELS LIKE OF
AN ART THAN A- SCIENCE. I WOULD
SAY THE NEXUS EXPERTS WOULD
PROBABLY THIS. OFFICIAL I WAS
MINISTER AND I HOUSING DIRECTOR
YOU GET A BETTER THE MAXIMUM
AMOUNT IN THE BUNCH THAT
THINKING. WHERE FOOT.
POLITICALLY UNTENABLE ANNEX
CANADA AND SOLUTIONS TO
POLITICAL WRESTLE THAT HAPPENED
IT CAME OUT EIGHTY DOLLARS PER
FOOT I THINK INDICATES WOULD
HAVE BEEN A LOT OF. THESE. YEAH
I THINK THERE'S PRETTY
ESTABLISH METHODOLOGY ON THE
NEXUS STUDY THE ISSUE WHERE HE
SAID THAT HE- ACCESS IS GOOD SO
YOU. LEGALLY AND THAT YOU CAN
ANYWAY. SO WHAT WE DID WAS LOOK
WHAT WITH THE MARKLE OUTFIT THE
AND THEN SET FEE THERE MANY
CITY. THAT AND SO WHERE THEY
SAID IT IS JUST BASED. AND
COMMUNITY AND. LAYS THANK YOU
AND THAT IS A GOOD REFER. BACK
TO EUROPE. THIS IS GO ABOVE IN
MY RESERVE CITY STEPPING BACK
IN CAME BACK A DIFFERENT NUMBER
REALLY HAD TO DO MORE ABOUT
STAYING WITHIN A BAND THE
POSTED AN ARBITRARY. EVER BUT
SORT OF SPEAKING TO I MEAN.
AFRICA HAS ALWAYS FRIEDMAN IS
GAME TO EARLIER ABOUT ANY
ZONING IN HER CITY. IT'S LIKE.
COULD BE ABILITY TO TRY TALK
ABOUT HOW DO WE PUT. TO THAT
THERE ARE A OUR SERVICE
ACCEPTED PRACTICES WITH THIS
EARN BUT THE VERY IS PRETTY.
DOUBLE TO ME TO HAVE THE WHOLE
TIME PLEASE FIVE INPUT ON THE
BACKS OF. MOTORS AND AN END TO
OUR RENT- I DON'T OF HIS WEIGHT
AND PUTS PORK- GUARDRAILS
AROUND THAT TO NOT HAVE SIX AT.
THE EIGHT. BE ON THE GEOGRAPHIC
AND- AND WAGED PROBABLY
DIFFERENT. MAYBE I DON'T. OWN
THE LAND QUESTION. DID THE
VARIATION FEELS. THAT I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED A LOT OF REGIONAL
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IMPACT I
THINK YOU YOUR VARIETY OF
OPINIONS. YOU WOULD ALSO. GET
THEIR FROM CERTAIN CITIES AND
SPITTING SPECIAL DISTRICTS. SO
DEPENDENT ON FEES THAT THEY
DELIVER THE SIR. IN OPEN IT'S
DIFFERENT- FEES ARE REALLY
SMALL OF OUR REVENUE. DESIGN
NOT PROHIBIT SO. YOU CAN THAT
WAY BUT YOU CERTAINLY THE
NUMBER OF BOOKS THE CHALLENGE
OF ANY KIND OF GUARDRAIL A
CONSTRAINT ON FEET BUT I THINK
IF WE COULD FIT A DIFFERENT WAY
TO FIX OUR AND IT REALLY COMES
OUR- OFFICE DOES AGE OF
LEBANESE AND HAPPY. ALLOW
GOVERNMENT TO PROVIDE. SO THAT
WE CAN FIX THOSE OTHER.
ELEMENTS THEN WE CAN LINE UP ON
FEES YEAH. I'M. THE FEE THAT
YOU SPOKE OUT IN THERE YES. IS
SIMPLY HOUSING FEE IT'S NOT THE
IT'S NOT THE WHOLE IF YOU LIKE
SCHOOL FIGURES TO MAKE THAT.
THAT'S RIGHT SO I WAS
SPECIFICALLY LOOKING TO DEVELOP
AN IMPACT THE CITY. AND SO WE
FOR A HOUSING IMPACT FEE THAT.
V. AND THEN A CAL FACILITIES
FREE OKAY THERE ARE OTHER FEET.
IS THERE'S DE. YEAH EACH IS
FROM OTHER DISTRICTS- OTHER
CHARGE IN THAT IS SO THOSE ARE
A IN WITH THE GRAPHIC DIFFERENT
BILL. VISINE NOTED THAT APPLIES
TO THOSE OTHER ONES. YOU JUST
THAT'S RIGHT THOSE PERCENT BY
THESE AND DID NOT. BUT WE DID.
THE ANALYSIS LOOK AT A COME
PROJECT PRO FORM THAT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT. PLEASE AND. LARRY THE.
YOU WERE YOU MADE IN YOUR
COMMENTS BUT JUST A PART OF A
POINT ON IT. WHEN YOU ABOUT THE
FREE MONTH. YOU WOULDN'T GO
THERE RIGHT YOU WOULDN'T TAKE
YOUR PRODUCT THERE YOU WOULDN'T
MAKE AN EFFORT THERE YOU JUST
USE OF THESE REALLY DETERMINE
WHERE YOU GO AND VOTER SHERMAN
IMPACT ON WHAT WE BUILT UP. WE
COULDN'T AFFORD TO BUILD ON
WITH THOSE. PRODUCT OR TALKING
ABOUT HERE IT IS WITH THIS CITY.
THE WAY ANYTHING WE. I DO DIAL
IT IS A BOX YEAH IT'S
ESSENTIALLY A DUPLEX THERE'S-
THEY'RE JUST THEY'RE ALL
CONNECTED ROOF. HI ABILITY TO
SELL THEIR SEPARATE BUILDINGS
BUT TECHNICALLY THE RIGHT NEXT
TO EACH OTHER THAT WAS A NEW
FOR ME AND- I WAS A NEW WAY TO
ADVANCE. TO SAY. THANK YOU BYE.
WHAT KINDS IN USE THESE DAYS
AND I'LL BE HERE FOR THE LINK
OUT. I GUESS I ONE MORE
QUESTION. WE DON'T HAVE A
MARKER REDEVELOP HERE YOU KNOW
WHO SORT OF CAN ANSWER SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS MAYBE YOU KNOW OR
JERRY WHEN YOU DID YOUR STYLE.
BUT YOU KNOW IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT. WHEN YOU TURN ANY KIND OF
FEE THAT SOMETHING HAS TO GIVE
IT SOME MORE SOMEONE HAS TO
GIVE. AND GIVEN THE HIGH COST
OF CONSTRUCTION PLANS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE ARE YOU. SAN
FRANCISCO OR OR. ARE YOU
LOOKING AT- THE IMPACT THAT.
THE. BUT YOU'RE- MORE
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING IS ON THE
RENTS OF MARKET RATE PRODUCTION
IN OTHER WORDS OTHER DEVELOPERS
AT ALL TO JUST OBSERVE ARE
THERE LIKE HEY WE HAVE TO PAY
THIS FEE THAT'S GOING TO GO FOR
A HOUSING AND WE JUST NEED AT
ALL OR THEY RAISING THEIR RENTS
OUT THEIR NEW THINGS TO PAY FOR
IT AND IF SO TO JUST CRUISE
CONTINUING. THAT YOU KNOW
PEOPLE AREN'T. YOU KNOW TO GET
YOUR SUBSIDY AREN'T WHAT. WAY
MORE PEOPLE WHO QUALIFY THAN
THEY EVER GET LOTTERY TO GET
ONE OF THESE UNITS. YOU ALSO TO
INCREASE. THAT'S GOING ON YOUR
BILL CLASS. I RENTER'S I DOING
THIS OR YOU'RE NOT SEEING A
CHANGE. YES NO MATTER. BUT I
WOULD SAY THAT WHEN YOU FEED
EITHER GONNA WRITE COST PRODUCT
THIS CASE YOU CAN'T REYES WHAT
PEOPLE MORE THAN A PEOPLE OF
EIGHTY FOUR ONE HEY SO YOU
CAN'T JUST SAY I'M GONNA PASS
THIS ON TO THE TUMOR OKAY
BECAUSE THIRTY SEVEN THE
WILLING HEY DO YOU HAVE TO TAKE
YOUR YOUR PROP. WHAT IS OUT OF
THE VALUE OF THE LAND. AND. GET
MUCH OF IT COMES OUT OF PROFIT
WE'RE NOT GONNA SEE DEVELOPMENT.
MOMENT THIS IS PART OF ELEMENT
YOU DON'T YOU THINK IN OAKLAND
IT'S NOT RAISING RENTS WHAT
ABOUT AN AREA THAT'S A NOT AS
HOT HOUSING IN YOUR- YOU KNOW.
THIS IS PRETTY UNIQUE IT'S AN
EXTREMELY HOT HOUSING MARKET.
VIEW WITH DOWN ON LOS ANGELES
BEVERLY HILLS I WORRY. THAT
THAT'S NOT THE CASE IN. BURBANK.
SO THERE IS A BIG RANGE OF
VALUES IN OAKLAND SO EAST OAK
AND OUR OUR WEAKEST REAL ESTATE
MARKET THAT'S WHY THE FEE WAS
SET AT ZERO. SO I THINK THE
QUESTION IS HOW MUCH DEPENDS
SENATE ZERO WHAT HAPPENED. WELL
WE'RE GETTING VERY LITTLE
MARKET DEVELOPMENT THERE. AND
SO WE CONTINUE TO SEE LACK OF
DEVELOPMENT THERE. YEAH I THINK
IT THREE THAT. IS SUPPOSED TO
WORK BUT IT HASN'T IN
CALIFORNIA FOR A LONG TIME SAID.
DID IT SHOULD FLOW TO THE LAMB.
GO DOWN IN PRICE AS A RESULT OF
INCREASED CALL US.
UNFORTUNATELY I AND AS IN ALL
THE CAN OCCUR THE NEW LANDFILLS
SO THEY SAY AND SO. GOING ON TO
THEIR POWER TING ON THE LAND
SIDE AND SO IT'S NOT REFLECTING
THE WAY THAT THE MARKET SHOULD
WORK AND SO THE ONLY WAY TO GET
IT BACK. THE PRIEST CASA BY
CREATING YOUR MUSIC TO INCREASE
SOME AS HIGH AS YOU CAN GET IN
THE MARKET THAT'S WHAT THE
SENATE SAYS INCREASE INCREASE
FRANCE. AND IF I MAY JUST ADD
ON THAT POINT- I THINK IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S VERY SPECIFIC
UNDER PROPOSITION THIRTEEN THE
LANDOWNERS ARE NOT SEEING THEIR
PROPERTY TAX INCREASE THE RATE
THAT WE ARE SEEING THE VALUES.
THANKS FOR THEIR STATE. CENTER
FOR AND- LAND. THANK YOU. IN A
LAST CHANCE FOR MANY THE PANEL
I'M ALSO A KIND OF REMINDER
THAT YOU KNOW A LOT OF THIS
AFTER HIS ABOUT INTAKE IDEAS
TENSION. STATION CAN OVERSIGHT
MATTERS YOU KNOW IN FOR ITEMS
BEFORE A COMMITTEES GOING FOR.
CERTAIN OPEN ENDED HIGHLY BUT
POINTED THAT SOMETIMES THE
VALUE THESE COMMITTEES ANY ANY
FINAL CONTACTS FOR THE
COMMITTEE. I'M NOT GONNA JUST
USES AN OPPORTUNITY I MEAN YOU
YOU SORT OF HIT ON AT THE
IMPACT WAS ONLY A- PERCENTAGE
OF THE COST. I MEAN WE'RE
SPENDING PRADA THIRD OF THE
COST OF OUR DEVELOPMENT IS JUST
ENTITLEMENTS BECAUSE OF THE
PROCESS. SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
NORMALIZE THE PROCESS OR START
TO RATIONALIZE THE PROCESS EVEN
IN TERMS OF ENTITLEMENTS. WILL
HAVE A HUGE HUGE IMPACT IT'S
GOING TO BE IN DEVELOPMENT I
WAS A PRIME. ON OUR OPERATE INS
INSTEAD OF JUST GO FOR ALL.
THERE IS SIR. TO CREATE A- THAT
DETERMINE FIVE THEY HAVE A
PROJECT IN SOME YOU KNOW IT
GOING IN AND NO YEAH THE
APPROVAL PROCESS IS A SIMPLE
AND HOW LONG IT'S GONNA TAKE IS
POOR AND SO AND- YOU CAN DO TO
NORMALIZE. PROCESS WE.
BENEFICIAL INTERPOSING OUTPUT
OF NEW PRODUCTION LARRY LE ASK
YOU IS TO DIE THAT A LITTLE BIT
MORE ARE YOU HAVING OUR-
ENTITLEMENT ISSUES WITH SEEK
WAS WAS OF A OR THEY ARE THEY
ARE THEY JUST PROCESS SO ACROSS
THE BOARD. DICTION IS
DIFFERENCE. THE HIGHER ORDER
SOMEONE PART IN EACH
JURISDICTION JUST TO BE. HM
THIS SYSTEMS. THE LEAST OF THE
COP WAS FOR SURE I'M DO WE WHEN
WE DO ANY AYE ARE NOW NOT ONLY
DO WE DO THE WE ALSO HAVE. AN
ATTORNEY TO REVIEW THE UP.
STATION OF BEING DONE TODAY ARE
BECAUSE IT HAPPENS A LOT OKAY.
IN ADDITION TO THAT YOU HAVE
CAN. COMMENTS WITH ALL THE
SPECIAL. THEN THIS FAVOR OF ALL
YOUR VETO WHERE IT JUST IT'S
TIME CONSUMING SIR AND WE'LL
TALK ABOUT ASSIST PROJECT
MANAGER PASSED. THANK YOU. BUT
ALSO AT. IN AN EFFORT TO MEET
OUR STATE A BILL I MENTAL
THERE'S A NUMBER OF OUR SAKE
ADDED A LINK UP AND LIVE OUT MY
ENTITLEMENT BUT WITH THE NEW
CALIFORNIA CODE THAT'S GONNA
COME ON NEXT YEAR CAN GET SOLAR
MANDATES ZERO ENERGY THE COST
AND- THE END RESULTANT IT'S
JUST STUFF THAT WE'VE DESIGNED
ASSIST WHAT WE ARE YOU SAYING
WE BUILD THE GOLD PLATED
COPPER. BE ON THE MARKET WON'T
PRODUCE YOU KNOW THE AFFORDABLE.
TIRED AS ANY SO WE'VE CREATED
THIS SYSTEM. THAT WE'RE SEEING
MIDDLE INCOME HOUSING GROUP.
USED TEST REDRAWING UNITS
ALTHOUGH THE MARKET ISN'T
REALLY PRODUCING THOSE BECAUSE
INVESTORS ARE PRODUCING THEM
FAMILIES ARE PRODUCED I'M SO
GETTING YOU. FUTURE INVEST FOR
CHANGING. STANCE AND THEN- SOME
CASES SOMETHING GIVE EITHER YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A YOU KNOW A ROUTE
AND PROPERTY TAX REDUCTION IN A
LAND COST TO IN IN THE STATE
HAS BEQUEATHED. INOTES
NONPROFIT UPPER OR. IN OKAY
ELIMINATED MOST OF OUR PARKING
REQUIREMENTS FOR EXAMPLE BUT
ANOTHER PART OF THE CITY
PARKING IS A HUGE EXPENSE SOME
US HAS TO GIVE SO I. STATE TO
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE VIEW OF
ALL THOSE COST. MUCH EASIER. TO
TACKLE THEM. BUT IT'S THAT THE
WHOLE PICTURE. THE HELPFUL LATE
CAN I JUST THANK YOU FOR THAT.
WHAT ARE YOUR REACTIONS TO THAT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION WE HAVEN'T
SEEN I MEAN I SAY THIS BECAUSE
I KNOW IT'S WELL INTENTIONED WE
SEEN AN ACTOR AT ALL IMPROPER
AS I HAVE TO KIND OF LAUGH IN
WAYS I'M- SORRY SARCASTICALLY
I'M AND BECAUSE DEALING WITH
THE WILD FIRES WE THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT DEMOCRATS.
DOING ACTUALLY IN SANTA ROSA
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GOING TO FIRE
VICTIMS AND WE CAN USE THOSE
THOSE VISIONS BEFORE THE AS
WITH THIS WAS GONNA LEVIN MONTH
ANTI PROCESS. LEGISLATION. AND
A FOCUS ON NEW HOUSING. NOW
THIS PROUD OF FOURTEEN MONTH
AND BEFORE CAME OUT SO JACKIE
GOT WORSE IT'S EVEN BETTER SO I
I'M NOT SURE. WE'VE YET ON A
SCALE SEEN I'M SURE ON A.
COMPLAIN TO I'M JUST NOT SAYING.
I GET IT IS SET ON IT IN THE
SENSE. AN EMERGENCY MEASURE IS
FOR A MINUTE PERIOD. AND THAT
SERVICE IS WHAT YOU WERE SAYING
A MOMENT AGO WANTING THAT
CERTAINTY PROCESS I THINK IN
SOME OF THE LEGISLATURE TRIED.
IT AGAIN. AUTHOR IS AN AMAZING.
THIS IS THE RECOGNITION WAS
POLITICALLY POSSIBLE POINT TIME
AND YOU KNOW IT BACK TO THAT
OVERSIGHT OBSERVATION IF WE.
SEE THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY
WORKED OUT PRETTY GOOD THE
CITIES ARE ADOPTED INTO IN
TAKING THE ECSTATIC COMPONENT
OF REVIEW THE VIEW TO HEART SEE
MAKE IT HAPPEN THAT WOULD BE
WORTHY OF CERTAINLY EXTENT BUT
MAYBE SOME SORT OF OPINION IN
LAW WE REALLY CAN I. CAN LOOK
AT THE STATE. AND DON'T YOU.
PROP WE WERE JUST STARTING TO
AND THOMAS AND I WILL HELP YOU
KEEP YOUR OF. ARMED IF THAT WE-
THE PROCESSES RESULT I WOULD
LOVE FEEDBACK- GOOD OTHER
REASON THIS PAN- I WILL TO.
OPEN THE FLOOR. I'M OVER HERE
IN ONE REYES. PUBLIC COMMENT
ABOUT IT ALL MENTION. KNOWLEDGE
AND THAT COMMON CAUSE AFTERNOON
WHY NOT I MEAN WITH. BUT YOU'RE
IS FOR A- TWO MINUTES. THANK
YOU- MY NAME IS KAREN I CAST I
AM- REGIONAL ORGANIZING FOR
CALIFORNIA MD YES IN MY
BACKYARD ONE THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE AND COMMUTING IT'S
REALLY CRITICAL STOCKTON. AND
JOINING US IN AN AREA WHERE WE
SEE. ONE OF THE DISTINCTIVE
FEATURES OF CALIFORNIA HOUSING
AS AS EXPRESSED IN A REALLY
STRONG WAY WHICH IS THE
CHALLENGES SPECIFICALLY THAT
WORKING CLASS AND MIDDLE CLASS
PEOPLE HAVE FORTY HOUSING- I
THINK ACROSS THE COUNTRY THERE
IS A CRISIS OF. AFFORDABILITY
FOR PEOPLE IN EXTREME POVERTY.
THAT'S ONE OF THE PAGES VISION
PROPERTIES IS VERY BUT BEFORE
ANYTHING. HOUSING VERY MUCH
INCLUDED- BUT I GREW UP. AND IN
IOWA. SOME OF THE PEOPLE OF
MIDDLE INCOME IN THIS AREA
WOULD. HI INCOME WHERE I GREW
UP- ARE ABLE TO DOESN'T I IN A
WAY THAT IS NOT THE CASE IN THE
BAY AREA AND CALIFORNIA. I
THINK INCREASING THE STATE IS
LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE I THINK A
LOT ABOUT NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE
LIVED IN SOUTH BERKELEY AND
NORTH OAKLAND. INCREDIBLE
DIVERSITY OF HOUSING TYPES. IN
THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS THERE ARE
SIX HOMES IN THERE ARE COMPLEX
IS IN THERE ARE SMALL APARTMENT
BUILDINGS THEIR MID SIZE OF THE
BILL. HI THAT'S WHAT IT IS WHAT
A GREAT DIVERSITY OF RESIDENTS
IN THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS ARE
DIVERSE AND RACE AND AGE AND
GENDER PRESENTATION AND
OCCUPATION AND NATIONALITY. ARE
BUT MOST OF THE BUILDINGS IN
THE HOODS WOULD BE ILLEGAL TO
BUILD TODAY. PLEASE I HAVE
LIVED IN. ILLEGAL TO BILL TODAY
I HOPE FOR THE. IN BERKELEY I A
PROVIDE TWENTY HAS TWICE AS
MANY AS ARE CURRENTS OWNING
DEFICIT RIDLEY SAYING IN THE
LAND USE POLICY WE MADE A
MISTAKE WILL OUT TOO MANY HOMES
TO BE BUILT HERE THERE ARE TOO
MANY PEOPLE LIVING- THE HERE
AND- WE'RE NOT LET LET THE
MISTAKES HAPPEN AGAIN. IT
DOESN'T RUN OF OUR STREET
PARKING- IT'S WITHIN THE
HIGHLANDS I'M SURE IT'S
VIOLATING SETBACKS UNLOCK
COVERAGE. AND THESE ARE ALL
SORT OF THE STATE EVEN IN A
RELATIVELY PRO HOW. XIN MOST OF
THE CONSTRUCTION THAT ICE HE IS
FOR SINGLE FAMILY HOUSING
RENOVATION. RATHER THAN NEW
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING THAT WE SO
DESPERATELY NEED BEING. I SO. I
THINK BLAH BLAH INTERNET IS TO
THE TELL ALL MY GRANDFATHER TO
BUY A HOME IN BERKELEY AS A
PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY
THERE I DON'T THINK A PROFESSOR
THE UNIVERSITY WOULD BE ABLE TO
DO AGAIN TO. NEED TO LOOK AT
THOSE BARRIERS- HAD A CALM A
LOT BECAUSE. HUNDRED PROGRAM IS
THE IS. YEAH THEY JUST LINE ON
A MAP AND THOSE COMMUNITIES
FACING THE SAME. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GLORY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN.
I'M THE DIRECTOR WITH DOES NOT
FIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION BY
THEMSELVES YEAH SO FIRST AS
LIKE YOU SO MUCH FOR HOLDING
HEARING HERE. IT'S AN
ORGANIZATION. OUR TRADITIONALLY
FOCUSED THE HOUSE FOR THE
LOWEST INCOME IN THE BAY AREA
BUT- WHICH- ARE HOUSING FOR THE
MISSING MIDDLE AND A TREND THAT
WE HAVE BEEN OBSERVING STATE
LEVEL HAS BEEN AT THAT LOCATION
SIGNIFICANT SUBSIDIES. ARE
MISSING MEN HOW OLD WHICH WE
THINK YEAH. ARE ANY. BUT
COMPARED TO THE LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS WHERE- WITHOUT THE
SUBSIDY IS THAT THE STATE
CURRENTLY PROVIDES THEY WOULD
HAVE A HOMES AT ALL WOULD BE
HOMELESS WE THINK THAT A LOT OF
THE PROBLEMS FOR MISSING MIDDLE
COULD BE ADDRESSED. THROUGH
ZONING REFORM. SHOULDN'T WE
HAVE TO EARN FOUR WE GET TO THE
DIRECT SUBSIDIES THOUGH THERE
IS ALSO A ROLE TO PLAY WITH
DIRECT SUBSIDIES WITHIN THE
HIGH COST OF THE STATE BUT
FRANKLY MOST OF CALIFORNIA
ISN'T YET IN AS EXTREMIST
SITUATION AS THE BAY AREA BUT
EVEN HERE WE- CAN DO A LOT MORE.
ZONING REFORM TO LOOK IMPACT
FEES AND SAYING. WE CAN
STRUCTURE THESE. MRS WITHOUT.
ME EASIER S. AS IN OR GET XIN
WE WILL CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON
THESE SO SOLUTIONS BECAUSE WE
REALLY BELIEVE IN RESERVING THE
SUBS. DOES. TOM I'LL MAKING IT
EASIER FOR THE MARKET PROVIDE
HOMES OF FOR THE FOR THE LITTLE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS WE WRAP UP THE MAIN PARTING
COMMENTS FOR. THE HEARING TODAY.
GLORIA FOR HAVING. THIS HEARING
BUT WE HAD NOW A COUPLE
HEARINGS AND THEY'VE BEEN VERY
VERY VALUABLE- YOU DO SEE THEM
IN THE LEGISLATURE ALL RIGHT UP
TO HER TO TACKLE A LOT OF
ISSUES. AND IT'S TOUGH BECAUSE
WE- A LOT. ONLY FILL IN
FIGHTING WITH OUR OWN LOCALITY.
SITUATIONS AND TRYING TO BE
MINDFUL DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES
AND DIFFERENT. AT ALL. AND
UNFORTUNATELY. WE HAVE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME IN OUR STATE OF THE
SPEAKERS MENTION SETTING UP A
ZONING LAWS THAT HAVE- NEEDED
TO WEAR FOR A LOT ARE RED. IT'S
REALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO LIVE IN
OUR- AND. NOW WE KNOW HAVE THIS
HUGE CRISIS THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT'S HOLDING US BACK KLAY AND
CAUSING BE LIVING UP. AND I PUT
WE BELIEVE YOU HAVE A
POSSIBILITY TAKEN. IF IT MAKES
A SOME POP. I JUST WISH. I
GUESS THAT MORE PEOPLE SAW THE
CONNECTION BETWEEN THEIR OWN ON
WILDERNESS TO SO MUCH HOW TO
LIVE A LITTLE BIT AND MAKING
ROOM FOR EVERYONE AND I ALSO
WE- ARE JOB. WITH THE DEMOCRATS
READING REALLY GOOD. HOLDEN I.
WAS I THINK THEIR JOB WITH THE
BEAR. MORE THAN A- BUT YOU KNOW
DANCE USUALLY HAS CUT THE COST
OF OUR COMMUNITIES RATHER THAN
ADDING TO COMMUNITIES I THINK
MAYBE GOES BACK TO A LITTLE
ABOUT THE LACK OF ABILITY TO
CREATE A VARIETY OF HOUSING
STYLE AND DOING IT IN PLACES
WHAT MAKES IT INTO FOR PEOPLE
TO BE TO LIVE. AND WORK ALL
AREA I. WATER RESISTANCE
BECAUSE OF DENSE WE'VE DONE
TEN. OFF CHANGE BUT I THINK
THAT'S GONNA BE PARTY EQUATIONS
WHERE PEOPLE THINK THAT IT'S AN
UPGRADE TO THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD
I'M NOT THE OTHER WAY AROUND I
WISH I COULD TAKE THEM OUT OF
SAN FRANCISCO AND- OAKLAND
BERKELEY. AND SHOW THEM HOW.
THIS TO BE IN A PLACE THAT. NO
MORE JOHNSON HOW YOU STILL HAVE
SIMPLY DOWN. AT. FOR US HE CITY
STREETS IN A BETTER QUALITY OF
LIFE AND A HEALTHIER. THAT'S
WHAT IT'S FOR A FOR ALL OF MY
CAN TO AND- EVERYONE. THERE HAS
TO BE JUST A SEC RIGHT THAT
EVERYBODY HAS SO. HELP US THANK
YOU GET TO GLORIA. THANKS FOR
TRAVEL. THANK YOU KNOW. THIS
HOUSE BILL ITSELF IN FACT VIDEO
TIME TO HELP US TRY TO HAVE A
BROADER CONVERSES BUT WHAT WE
CAN DO IT'S PERSONALLY
MEANINGFUL A TWO- I WANT TO
THANK MEMBERS MY STAFF WILL
THIS TOGETHER- PROFITS AND
STEVE HEALTH FOR MY DISTRICT
OFFICE A GERMAN THINK WE WORK.
IN THE BACK TO HELP MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S A BROAD AUDIENCE
FOR THAT JOHN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AND FORCE YOUR AND-
AUTHORIZES COMMITTEE TO EXIST
WE HAVE A STANDING COMMITTEE OF
HOUSING WHICH IS IMPORTANT AND
THAT'S WITH A LINE SHARE THIS
WORK IS. BUT HAVE A CSUS LIKE.
EXPRESSED FOCUSED ON MIDDLE AND
WORKING CLASS. I THINK. NEWARK
I WOULD HAVE. TO START- YEAH I
THINK IT'S AN INDICATION IT
BACK TO. TEACHER AND IS ANYONE
SACRAMENTO NO THAT THAT'S HOW
ARE THEY DOING ABOUT IT. AND
THAT THE MULTIPLE YEARS IS
COMMITTEES BEEN AROUND WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO GENERATE. A PIECE
OF LEGISLATION INTERNET LAW-
SOME THAT REQUIRE OVERSIGHT A
FOLLOW UP TO SEE A JURISDICTION
BUT IMPLEMENTING. IN SUMMER
PILOT PROGRAMS NEED TO BE
EXPANDED THE POINT IS THAT
THESE HEARINGS. ACROSS THE
STATE I THINK A VERY HELP. A
FOR TRYING TO GET. THREE MINS
POINT ABOUT WHAT PRODUCTION
ADDITIONAL SUPPLY LOOK LIKE.
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AS THEY WORK
TO THIS PROCESS TO MAKE SURE
THESE IMPLEMENTATIONS ARE DONE.
THIS LAST CONVERSATION. THIS
FRIEDMAN TALKS ABOUT TO FIND
OUT WHICH IS IMPORTANT I
RECOGNIZE- NOBODY WANTS IN AN
UGLY IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD I
GET IT SOME OF THE CITY OFF TO
SAY THAT WE DON'T WANT ANYMORE
HOUSING TO THE INFRASTRUCTURE
COMES BACK AND YOU ARE QUITE
POINTED AT THE CHICKEN A
CONVERSATION. YOU HAVE TO KIND
OF GET AHEAD. MORE
SPECIFICALLY. WHAT ABOUT THE BY
SAYING THAT THERE'S NOTHING
ABOUT THIS COMMITTEE. IS
INTENDED TO BE EXCLUSIVE OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE. VERY
CUTE FOR I'M SHELTERED
CALIFORNIA. IT WAS VERY LOW AND
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIA. I'M
HOUSING IS A- AND RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE A LOT OF THINGS THAT. A
COUPLE AROUND THE VERY BOTTOM
BUT NOT MUCH AND MEAN AND PEDRO
WITH YOUR HERE AS- IS OUR STATE
HOUSING BUT- THAT HOUSING IS
HELPFUL- IT IT DOES HELP TO
LOW. INCOME CALIFORNIANS AND
THE ON SHELTERED CALIFORNIA.
OUR PASSION ABOUT LADDERS
PRETTY EXTREME WHEN PEOPLE FALL
OFF THAT COME HOMELESS AS WE GO
CALIFORNIA HAS ROUGHLY 25% OF
ANY. ALTERED AND THAT'S NOT
GONNA CHANGE UNTIL WE RE
ESTABLISH. A FUNCTIONAL LADDER
LADDER WITH RUNS AT THREE. AS
THE UPPER MOBILITY THAT BOB IS
TO HAVE. COME TO YOU WITH THE
EXPERIENCE OF HAVING. AT THE
SENATE HOTEL MADE A GARDENER
WHO WOULD EXTREMELY HARD IN
SANDY. WE WILL BUY A HOME AND
PUT THEIR TO. FIRST EVER GOT.
YEARS AGO AND I THINK
CALIFORNIA TODAY MAY NOT
PARTNER. ISN'T TO LIGHT. THE
MAKER EVERY AND LOCAL ELECTED
IF IT. EVERY EMB IN THE IN IN
BETWEEN OUT. DEDICATED TO THE
IDEA THAT IF YOU WORK HARD
ENOUGH AND FOLLOW ALL IN THE
STATE. THE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
SUCCEED FUTURE HERE AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS COMMITTEES ABOUT. CAN
SURE THAT IS. THE FACT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF EXPERT WE
HAVE THAT THERE MAY LOW INCOME
HOUSING IS WE HAVE A PROPER
TEMA LOTS OF THINGS THAT ARE
APPLICABLE TO LOW INCOME IT. I
WANNA MAKE THE POINT I REALLY
WE SHOULD BE SUBSIDIZING THIS
PART WE WILL THAT'S NOT OPTIMAL.
HAVE A WAGE REALLY SHOULD NEED
PUBLIC SUBSIDY INCREASING
THAT'S WHAT AND MAYBE IT'S
TEMPORARY SITUATION- WE REBUILD
THIS LATTER HOUSING IT'S DENNIS
THAT WE NEED TO USE FORGET. THE
SERMON. THIS SENATE ABOUT HOUSE
WE HAVE TO HASH IN ABOUT IN
EVERY COMMUNITY AT EVERY INCOME
LEVEL FOR EVERY CALIFORNIA
MISTREATMENT OF A VERY SPECIFIC
AND I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE A
PHOTO CALIFORNIANS HAVE. A
HOUSING IS A HUMAN RIGHT. TO
ALL KINDS OF SLOGANS THAT ARE
OUT THERE. CONVERSATION I WILL.
TODAY